Yeah.
All right.
We're live,
sir.
First of all,
thank you very much for coming on and
really appreciate it.
I've enjoyed your youtube video.
I wouldn't say I've enjoyed I,
I haven't enjoyed them,
but I've been puzzled by them.
Been puzzled by the subject and for
people who have no idea what's going on.
Let's sort of unpack this for them.
In Canada,
Canada is very different than the United
States.
I love Canada.
I'm a giant fan of Canada.
There's one place I would live outside
of the US.
100 percent.
It would be Canada.
I love it up there.
I think the people are at least 20
percent more polite than America,
but you've got some weird shit going on
up there and your king.
What's the,
what do you call him?
Prime Minister Trudeau.
That fella to the Castro,
the Castro lover.
I was just going to say that this
fucking guy and people have been posting
today all the atrocities that Castro
committed during this regime to sort of
show how proposed firing squad deaths.
Few thousand.
How about all the different people that
they executed and then sold their blood
to the Viet Cong.
That one,
this wonderful,
wonderful man.
He was a wonderful man that,
that fucking savage,
um,
Trudeau in what he represents is I think
the good side of it,
what he's trying to do,
the trying to make a kinder,
more progressive,
more inclusive country,
but along the way,
what they're doing is they're,
they're promoting what you would call
online social justice warrior values and
some of them are a little preposterous.
You are one of the very few academics
who have fought against some of these
ideas that are not just being promoted
but are being enforced and enforced and
written into law.
And one of them is about gender
pronouns.
Um,
w when would mean by gender pronouns is
not just he and she,
but a whole slew of invented gender
pronouns,
gender pronouns that you're going to be
compelled to use.
Yeah.
You're already compelled to use.
And and likely in the states to,
even though people don't know it yet,
certainly in New York and the
employment,
a EOC has already ruled on that with
regards to businesses for theu ,
s and businesses.
And I believe also landlords,
I think.
Yeah.
So if your landlord chooses to ms dot
gender you and not just mis-gender you,
like if you're a transgender woman,
you used to be mad.
Now you're a woman and they call you a
he.
It's not just that like you're compelled
to use how many.
What is the,
what are those,
the number of them.
Now,
while there there's no standard
nomenclature for the non gender or the
further nonbinary types.
There's many,
many invented words.
And which of those you're supposed to
use is dependent entirely on the
subjective choice of the person that
you're talking with.
Now,
most people I believe out there
listening are going,
what the hell are they talking about?
Right now we're talking about as as 70
plus invented gender pronouns,
like Zi x above zero h I r a bunch of
weird ones and this is for people that
don't necessarily think they're a.
He or a she,
so they prefer these things.
On top of that,
you have animal kin,
which other kids,
other kids himself,
which was the one I thought most abusing
worm self.
That's for the low self esteem.
Other kids.
This is people that truly believe that
they are in the wrong body and that they
should have been born some form of
animal and would like you to refer to
them as this animal.
Your Elf or Elf or a fairy or a Pixie
Pixie.
Ken.
I haven't seen Pixie kid.
That's a good one,
but just get on.
Tumbler got to get onto.
Yes,
absolutely.
That's where it all goes down.
I'm professor Peterson.
What the Hell's going on?
What is this?
Well,
I think it's partly.
It's partly a form of narcissism.
Yes,
it's.
It's a.
it's partly a consequence of,
of the re,
of the rise of the new rise again of of
say Marxist doctrine.
I would say it's part of postmodernism.
Maybe it's postmodernism more than
anything else because the postmodernists
that's a philosophical.
A community,
let's say,
believed that the entire point of human
categorization is power and that
dialogue between people is only a power
dialogue and that there's no real
reality outside of interpretation and
that basically what we do is exchange
interpretive viewpoints to ratchet up
our dominance and status and that's that
and there's no biology as an ideology
and the idea of the objective world is
an ideology and sciences and ideology
and it's all interpretation all the way
down like turtles all the way down.
What?
What do you mean by it's all about
power?
Like in what way?
Well,
imagine that,
that there are groups of people who are
competing in the world for resources I
suppose,
and that it's a zero sum game and it's
every group against every other group
and the reason that we engage in
dialogue isn't to establish the truth or
move towards some,
some closer approximation of reality,
but to structure this social interaction
so that our group comes up on top.
Right?
And that it.
That is really what the problem is with
all this is that it's not just a matter
of choosing to be defined in one way,
but compelling others to define you in
that way.
The most,
most awful elements of it I think is the
idea that individuals should be defined
in terms of their group identity at all.
I mean you could argue,
and this is one of these weird
inversions,
so characteristic of this chaotic state
that we're in.
When people originally started fighting
against unfair discrimination and and I
say unfair
discrimination because lots of
discrimination is fair.
If you discriminate against people on
the basis of their competence,
that's perfectly reasonable.
It's unfair discrimination that that
constitutes the proper battleground for
people who have a more egalitarian
viewpoint,
but the initial idea was to eliminate
the proclivity for people to be
categorized according to their group
identity because that was interfering
with everyone's ability to view them as
as competent individuals.
But that got flipped probably in the
seventies after the Soviet state.
So self evidently was revealed as a
catastrophe.
That that got flipped so that the world
was turned into one group against
another power struggle from one group
against another,
and then the social justice warrior
types in the lefties,
even the Democratic Party started
categorizing everybody according to
their ethnic or sexual or racial
identity and made that the canonical
element of their being and that's an
absolutely terrible thing to do it.
It leads to in the Soviet Union.
When that happened,
for example,
when they introduced that idea along
with the notion of class guilt.
So for example,
when the Soviets collectivize the farms,
they pretty much wiped out or or raped
and froze to death.
All of their.
All of their competent farmers,
they.
They called them Kulaks and they
attributed class guilt to them because
they were successful peasants and they
define their success as oppression and
theft.
They killed all of them,
pretty much ship them off to Siberia and
frozen to death and they were the
productive agriculturalists in the
Soviet Union.
And then in the 19 thirties in the
Ukraine because of that,
about 6 million Ukrainian starved to
death,
but the Soviets were big on collective
guilt.
And all of these things that you hear
about now,
like white privilege for example,
they're there are variants of collective
guilt.
I,
I pick your bloody identity,
whatever it happens to be,
and then I make you a guilty member of
that category and then you and the rest
of the guilty members of that category
are judged as a,
as a unit.
It's absolutely it's murderous,
pushed to its extreme,
and we've seen that many,
many times.
Yeah,
you're oppressed or your,
your,
your opinions rather a suppressed and
you are automatically put into this
category of people who should be
dismissed because of the fact that you
have white privilege.
You should step back and let others
talk.
You should step back and this is a
narrative that gets repeated over and
over again in a social justice warrior
culture.
This idea that you should just step back
and let these others talk because they
understand as long.
Yeah.
And the others are always other group
members,
right?
And somehow their,
their discourses to be privileged in
reverse because hypothetically,
they're a member of an oppressed class.
Of course,
then you can multiply the numbers of
oppressed
classes ad Nauseum,
which is another part of the problem.
Yeah.
I like the idea is that in giving them
privileged because they have been
marginalized,
you will balance things out and you will
somehow another reverse the scale.
Yeah.
And that's another example
of the class based guilt idea.
You know,
it's um,
it doesn't seem to me self evident that
I'm to blame for slavery for example.
I mean,
being a Canadian,
it's a slightly different situation I
suppose,
but the,
the,
the idea that as the member,
as a member of a culture,
that you're somehow responsible for the
past sins of that culture.
Let's say it,
it,
it's a very,
very anti western ethos.
It goes along with this idea of class
guilt because your group membership is
the most important thing.
If your group at some point in the past
did something reprehensible,
which of course every group has done,
that's for sure.
Then you are de facto responsible in the
present for that.
How do you think we got to this point
where people are repeating these
patterns that were ultimately incredibly
unsuccessful and dangerous and deadly in
the past?
Like Marxism for example,
like people proudly proclaim themselves
as having Marxist ideology,
one in five,
one in five social scientists claimed to
be a Marxist,
kind of understand the history.
Why don't you fill people in on how that
went bad?
Well,
the estimates vary,
but in the Soviet Union between 19,
19 in 1959,
somewhere between 30 and 50 million
people were killed in internal
oppression alone.
So that's pretty bad.
And then,
and,
and in China,
uh,
which was operating under exactly the
same principles,
might have been up to 100 million killed
during Mao's time.
And of course my was still revered in
China appallingly enough.
Um,
and Vietnam,
Vietnam and Cambodia and wherever these
ideas were implemented,
Cuba,
wherever these ideas were implemented,
the result was absolute mayhem,
absolute mayhem.
And I think what happened is that the
Marxist ideas are actually quite
attractive if you're an intel
electrical.
And if you're,
I would say,
if you're tilted towards compassion from
a personality perspective,
because they're based on doctrines like
from,
from each,
according to his ability to each
according to his need and the idea that
you should fulfill people's needs or
that society should fulfill people's
needs,
is on the surface of it,
and attractive idea.
Of course,
the problem is who gets to define the
needs and who gets to define the
abilities and that really is a big
problem and well,
and then those ideas were put into
practice a first in the Soviet Union.
And Alexander Solzhenitsyn who wrote the
Gulag archipelago,
did a very lovely job of detailing,
uh,
in,
in horrifying detail how those initial
doctrines were transformed into
legislation.
And then how those legislation was
transformed into endless genocide
essentially and almost destroyed the
world.
Let's not forget that I'm partly with
the W,
partly with the help of Castro who just
died.
Um,
the,
the doctrines when,
when put into practice in,
into,
into actual practice were,
were murdered us instantaneously.
Now what happened,
they're always apologists for the left
in the West,
especially in France,
especially among the French
intellectuals,
especially in the late 19 sixties and
then when,
when all of the information about what
was happening is in the Soviet Union
came flooding forward and that
culminated say in 19,
19,
73 wouldn't.
Soldier Netter's book was published.
The French intellectuals changed their
tune instead of agitating on a part of
the working class,
which was which allied them with a
murderous marxists.
They switched and started talking about
power and to talk about group identity.
It was like a sleight of hand.
The underlying pathological philosophy
remained exactly the same,
but the surface nomenclature changed and
that became very attractive and it at
the same time the Soviet Union
dissolved.
And so one of the problems I think we
have now a perverse problem is that
these Marxist ideas are very attractive
to compassionate intellectuals and we
don't have good,
bad examples like the Soviet Union
around that.
Everybody can point to and go,
yeah,
well that sounds good,
but you know,
what about the murderous death camps in
the millions of people who are
suffering.
We still have North Korea,
but you know,
people treat North Korea like it's a
joke instead of like it's an exemplar of
a pathological system and,
and people have no historical memory
like my students and that's partly
because they're taught so badly in
schools is they have no idea what
happened in the Soviet Union.
They have absolutely no idea.
They know a little bit about the Second
World War maybe and of course people
generally know about the Holocaust,
but they have no idea what happened in
the Soviet Union.
So they have no idea where these ideas
could lead.
And,
and the,
and the universities and the high
schools are so full of people who are
radically left leaning that they're
never taught any,
that students are never taught any
proper history.
You know,
they're taught about the evils of
capitalism and you know,
I mean it's not like.
It's not like any system is perfect,
but there's difference between imperfect
and and consciously murderous.
I think one of the things that you've
just said that's very important is that
it's attractive to compassionate
intellectuals.
People that without really looking at
what the potential for these,
the these laws and regulations with the
negative potential for them is that the,
the underlying inclination to lean
towards that is that you,
you,
you care about people and then you,
you want people to be okay and yeah,
when you're kind of treating them like
they're your children's and,
and I don't mean that in an entirely
sarcastic manner.
It's reasonable in some sense to treat
other people like people that you love.
Although it's not reasonable and in very
many other ways,
which is why you don't invite every
stranger on the street to come and live
with you in your house.
I mean everybody puts up boundaries and
you have to do that,
but.
And people tend more than than we ever
expected.
And I've done a lot of research in my
lab that people do tend to vote and
think their temperament a lot more than,
than anyone really realizes.
And,
and if you're kind and that's your
highest virtue,
then you tend to treat people like
they're kin because that's what kind
means,
right?
It said an extension of the word kin,
but that doesn't work well in larger
groups.
You need other principals and so you
look at something like the idea of of
equity,
which is equality of outcome rather than
equality of opportunity.
On the surface of it,
it seems perfectly reasonable to say,
well,
if every resource isn't distributed
absolutely equally to every group,
then the system is unfair and on the
face of it,
that's a reasonable proposition,
but it falls apart under minimal
examination.
So here's something to think about for,
for all,
for everyone who thinks that equality of
outcome is a good idea,
it's like why the hell are you striving
for anything?
Then?
Because the reason anyone strives to
better themselves or to develop a skill
or to move forward in life at all is to
produce inequality.
You're trying to rise above the mediocre
masses every time you make an effort at
anything.
And so everything that we associate a
positive movement forward to a positive
motivation is actually an attempt to
render the world more on equal.
Now you're rendering and on we equal in
adjust way,
right?
Because we might say,
well,
if you work really hard,
you deserve and unequal outcome.
Well yeah,
unless you want people to stop working
hard.
And that was the old joke in the Soviet
Union,
you know,
they pretend to pay us,
we pretend to work.
So it's.
So it's,
it's,
it's so thoughtless that that's,
that's the problem.
That is a big problem.
The phrase income inequality,
do you never hear effort inequality?
Because the effort,
oh well,
you know,
in,
in some on some campuses,
and this is true in California,
it's now considered a,
a form of aggression.
It's classified under the
microaggression to say that hard work is
the one,
one of the reasons that people
accumulate more,
accumulate more value,
accumulate more property,
accumulate more money.
It's,
it's,
it's an aggression.
It's aggressive to say that because it
implies that people who who are poor
don't work hard.
Now,
see,
that's another terribly fuzzy form of
thinking because there are lots of
reasons for people to not have money,
many to be poor,
let's say,
which is even,
which is even different than not having
money,
alcoholism,
drug addiction,
mental illness,
physical illness,
intellectual incapacity and lack of
work,
all of those things,
so environmental factors.
What communities grow up into,
what you're being exposed to.
People imitate their atmosphere.
You're around people that are constantly
in trouble with the law and you're
dealing with horrible environments.
There's a lot of factors and I think
that one of the things that's really
important about having these discussions
is that they,
they break down these rigid ideologies
that a lot of these kids that are going
to these universities are sort of being
shoved into their shoved into these
ideology.
You're either on the left or you're on
the right and there's very few on the
right.
There's no open market of ideas when it
comes to discussing these things.
You're compelled and enforced into
surgeon.
He's a psychologist at the New York,
New York University business school.
He's done a really good job
documenting the dearth of ideological
viewpoints,
let's say political or temperamental
viewpoints because that's more accurate
in the modern university and its
appalling because with along with all
this push for ethnic and sexual and
racial diversity,
which I think is just a mask to enforce
a kind of ideological homogeneity,
there's no even understanding that
ideational diversity is the only
relevant value for for a university.
The rest of it's all predicated on the
assumption that if you do select people
because of their ethnicity or racial
background or gender,
that that will in and of itself produce
diversity of ideas,
which is another really pernicious idea
because it assumes that and it's so
contradictory.
The left describes anything that's
associated with the assumption that
someone who's female for example,
will think in a female way.
They regard that as an unreasonable
prejudice.
You have to perfectly reasonable to say
that we need more women in x discipline
because they will bring in female ideas.
It's like,
well,
what?
What?
What the hell are female ideas?
You can't have it both ways unless
you're completely in,
unless you don't care at all about
coherence or consistency and ideologues
really don't because they care about
putting their ideology fourth,
but the idea that you're going to get a
diversity of ideas because you have a
diversity of of class of people,
assumes that ideas and identity are the
same thing and that's an absurd
proposition.
In fact,
that's that's.
That's an essentially racial racist
proposition.
Black people think differently than
white people.
It's no some do and some don't,
and the overlap is substantive than the
difference between the individuals is
far greater than the difference between
the group.
I think we also need to make a very
clear distinction between discrimination
and people that are just inclined to
gravitate towards different careers and
different focuses.
There is a big difference between women
being forced out of tech and women being
not as compelled to enter into tech
careers as men,
but we're well that,
that,
that tech,
the tech issue is a really interesting
one for a couple of reasons.
One is that of course,
high tech basically developed after the
playing field for men and women was more
or less level,
I mean that happened in the 19 seventies
and despite that there weren't any near
anywhere near as many women in tech.
There's far more women in caring
professions and you see that
particularly in Scandinavia where
they've done everything they can to
equal to equalize the playing.
It's 20 to one female to male nurses and
20 to one male to female engineers.
Matt,
if you could the Scandinavian issue
because it's very interesting.
Yeah,
that's done over there and what the
results of them.
Yeah.
Well imagine that.
There are two reasons that people differ
there.
There are more than two,
but just imagine for the time being that
there are two.
One is for environmental reasons,
cultural reasons,
and the other is for biological reasons.
What happens if you flatten out the
environmental reasons,
which is what's happened in Scandinavia
is you maximize the biological
differences.
You don't get rid of them,
you maximize them.
And so what's happened in Scandinavia is
that men and women are more different
from a temperament,
personality perspective,
and also in terms of their interests.
They're more different in scandinavia
than they are anywhere else in the
world.
Now,
what have they done to try to flatten
things out?
As you say?
Well,
they've transformed their social policy
so that men and women have as close to
equal opportunity say,
as any society has managed,
but that hasn't produced the hope for
equality of outcome.
Quite quite the contrary in many
situations.
It's exaggerated it and you could say
that,
that that's actually okay.
Is that what you want?
What you want is to have a society where
the genuine differences between people
are free to manifest themselves.
So for example,
if you,
if you have three or four kids,
say the kids are going to be a different
from one another genetically,
that's why they're not identical twins.
They differ genetically and if you set
the environment up so that each child is
supportive,
that children actually turned out quite
differently.
Now,
if you're an absolute brute and you beat
them and you abused them,
then they'll all turn out the same
because there's tremendous environmental
influence on them then,
but if you,
if you form an individual relationship
with each of them and allow their
strengths to manifest themselves as they
will in,
in a,
in a supportive environment,
and the kids are going to turn out very
different and so a free society is
actually one that that produces
massively unequal outcomes because it
allows the genuine differences between
people to manifest themselves.
These people who are pushing equity at,
which is equality of outcome.
That's what the word equity codes for.
By the way,
equality of outcome and not equality of
opportunity.
I don't know what in the world they do
with regards to the fact that a very
large number of professions are high
quality,
high,
high paid professions are female
dominated physicians,
for example,
psychologists,
um,
any,
any of the disciplines that have to do
with human care almost inevitably
dominated by women.
And that's increasingly the case is that
we're supposed to stop that.
Is that also a sign of oppression?
We're going to force women to do things
they're not interested in.
Well,
there's also a very disingenuous way of
framing it here in America where people
consistently,
even the president of United States,
Obama was talking about income
inequality and the way they frame income
inequality.
They talk about the seventy nine cents
to the dollar,
but what they don't discuss that we're
talking about completely different
careers.
We're not.
The way they frame it,
they frame it as if two people are
working side by side.
One is a man,
one is a woman.
They're both doing the same job.
The man makes a dollar.
The woman who makes seventy nine cents,
that is not the case.
It's typical of ideological
conversation because what happens
technically,
like imagine that a given.
We talked about poverty a few minutes
ago and you said,
well,
there's,
there's many,
many reasons that one person might have
more money than another.
Um,
there are many,
many reasons why women might make less
money on average than men.
There.
There are small businesses that women
run,
for example,
make far less money than men's,
the small businesses that men run.
But that's partly because a lot of women
run their businesses part time because
they have kids.
It's also partly because men do all the
horrible,
dangerous jobs,
the ones where there's a high chance of
dying,
men are much more likely to work
outside.
Um,
men are much more likely to move in,
in pursuit of a career opportunity.
There are lots of reasons that,
that men and women differ in terms of
their income.
But if you're an idiot log,
you can only handle one variable.
Oh,
men and women measured on mass don't
have the same incomes.
Therefore the system is corrupt.
Jesus,
how much thinking does it take to come
up with a,
with a theoretical scenario like that?
So boneheaded and it just runs,
it just pushes the ideological,
uh,
it just pushes the ideology forward with
no thought.
Now,
as a professor,
why is this sort of objective reasoning
and really absolutely honest assessment
of this situation?
Why is it so rare amongst professors?
Why is it so rare in universities?
Why is this such an unusual subject?
Well,
I think the reason is is that when,
when people first encounter a complex
topic like income differences,
it's like imagine you were drawing a map
of the territory and you don't know the
territory very well.
The first thing you do is just roughly
sketch out the shapes of the continence
and maybe you're wrong.
Like the early European maps of North
America,
you know,
you kind of get one coastline,
right?
Guests and the rest it's blurry and gray
and then as you investigate more and
more,
your picture of the situation becomes
higher and higher and higher and higher
resolution.
It's hard to go from a low resolution
representation to a high resolution.
Representation and ideologies are low
resolution representations.
So the thing about a low resolution
representations is it looks like it
covers everything,
but it doesn't.
The closer you look,
the more details there are.
You know,
if you get a three year old to draw a
helicopter,
they put like a little cross on the top
and a circle in a stick and another
circle.
And that's the helicopter.
Well,
you know,
when you look at it,
that's a helicopter,
but no one would expect that thing to
fly.
If you want to change that into a real
model of a helicopter,
you have to increase your focus and
concentration on every single element of
the entity and that takes a tremendous
amount of cognitive effort and sometimes
you don't even know what you don't know
about something.
You know?
I could say,
well,
there are 50 reasons why men and women's
income differ.
Well,
that doesn't mean I can all
50 of those differences in each of those
50 differences are fragmented into maybe
another dozen categories each.
Maybe there's 600 reasons why men and
women's salary differ,
but you have to spend a tremendous
amount of time paying attention and
thinking to build your model of reality
into that level of resolution.
And basically what you do is default to
temperamentally,
I'm influenced ideologies.
They give you a one bit answer to
everything.
Why are men and women?
Why do men and women's salaries
different oppression?
It's always the same thing and it makes.
It makes you feel like you know
something and people like that because
they don't like the I the feeling that
there's something they don't know,
they don't like to be in chaos.
That's basically chaos.
They like to be an order.
An order is where you know everything so
and professors are no different,
no different than than than people
obviously.
Given that there are people,
maybe they're more intelligent on
average.
They're also more sheltered,
I would say in many ways on average and
they're also not challenged as often
tenure,
10 years in issue and also not competing
in the marketplace,
not being in the workforce,
going from being in high school to being
in universities,
to getting a degree to teaching,
to being a professor,
to getting tenured,
staying inside of that intellectual
bubble.
Yeah.
Well it's complicated.
Often these things,
these things happen.
They're like positive feedback loops.
You know,
when you bring a speaker too close to
her microphone,
too close to a speaker and it starts to
howl and I think something like that's
happened in the universities is that
they started to tilt towards the left in
the sixties and then as they tilted they
tilted harder and as they tilled it
harder,
they tilt it even harder until all of
the diversity was forced out of the
universities and I don't know if it's so
much a consequence of the actual
policies of the university as,
as just a feedback process that got out
of control.
I mean if it's 50 percent liberals and
50 percent conservatives,
no,
no problem.
But if it's 70 percent liberals and 30
percent conservatives,
maybe it rapidly goes to 99 percent
liberals and one percent conservatives.
Is that what it's like right now?
I mean,
what is it when you look at the
University of Toronto,
where you are,
what,
what is the number?
If you had to guess?
Well,
it would depend to some degree on the
discipline,
but,
but professors are also also tend to be
characterized by personality traits that
do tilt them towards liberalism.
They're higher in trait openness,
which is both creativity and interest in
ideas.
That's one of the things that
temperamentally distinguishes liberals
from conservatives.
Conservatives are more conscientious,
they're more orderly and industrious
liberals are more open,
so they're more interested in aesthetics
and ideas and of course being interested
in this statics and ideas does tilt you
towards an academic career.
Um,
it's hard to tell.
I mean it certainly the bulk of the bulk
of intellectuals are,
are liberal and liberal,
left virtually all of them I would say.
And then that's probably not,
that's not as true.
We know this is not as true in the hard
sciences,
but in the social sciences and the
humanities,
it's the overwhelming majority.
I mean,
I could see that even in this,
in this battle that I've been in Canada
with regards to bill [inaudible] in
these compelled pronouns that almost no
support from my faculty colleagues now.
I didn't expect any.
I mean,
and I'm not shocked by that,
but,
but it's an indication that if you put
to them a choice between social justice
slash all consuming compassion and
freedom of expression,
they're going to tilt hard towards the,
the social justice compassion end of
things.
It almost seemed like when I was
watching some of the debates that you've
engaged in,
it almost seems like they're
politicians.
Some seems like they,
their wedding,
their finger and going with the breeze.
There's some conversations that you had
that were just.
I had to stop and rewind them because I
couldn't believe the arguments.
There was a woman,
I don't know it was.
Was it a transgender man that you were
having a discussion with that was saying
that there's no difference?
No biological difference in the sexist,
new biological difference.
He said that the scientific consensus
for the last court date,
I'm not sure.
I'm not.
I don't believe so.
He,
he was a professor who taught
transgender studies at the University of
Toronto and yeah,
and he said outright that there were no
biological differences between men and
women and that that was the scientific
consensus.
And he and he believed that he had the
qualifications to say that because he
was a historian of medicine,
which,
which hardly qualifies as scientists,
not that you have to be a scientist to
notice that there are biological
differences between men and women.
It was very bizarre for me at that at
that point in this in the last few
months because I was under substantial
pressure from the university to stop
repeating my claim,
that I wouldn't use compelled pronouns
to refer to people because the
university regarded that is against the
university policies and also against the
Ontario Human Rights Code.
So also illegal and as my employers,
they're responsible for everything.
I say whether or not there has been a
complaint made,
whether or not the consequence of my
speeches intended or unintended because
that's built into the legislation and
believe me,
that's coming your way because this
legislation spreads like mad,
but on the one hand I was.
I got two letters of warning from the
university for refusing to use these
compelled pronouns,
which I regard as the ideological
constructions of radical left wingers
and this professor went on the agenda.
This is Ontario new show and announced
publicly that there are no biological
differences between men and women.
It was like,
Huh.
You think maybe the university would
have had something to say about that
since they do in fact have a biology
department,
but.
Oh No.
That,
that,
that went by without notice.
That was perfectly fine.
Is saying it's such an insane thing to
say if there's no biological difference
than why they taking hormones.
Well,
that's a good question.
Why bother with the surgery and the
horror?
Especially the hormones.
Yeah,
because that's not like you could argue
with surgery that that's cosmetic,
right?
This person,
whoever this professor
was as a expert in transgender studies,
Nicholas,
Matt,
um,
I'm pretty sure that used to be a woman
or she,
they.
You're not allowed to say that if you
say that you're a bad person,
if you say they and they in them is the
most reasonable of these,
a pronoun,
these alternative pronouns,
they and them,
like you could say,
if you know a guy and he does know how
to swim,
they should probably stay out of the
pool.
Right?
Right.
You can say that you could use that in a
non polar will form.
Yes,
and they is used to repair awkward
sentences basically,
but it's never been used despite the
claims of the of the gender bender
activists.
It's never been used for the singular
and we shouldn't.
We shouldn't,
we shouldn't,
we shouldn't.
All just language.
We don't give up the distinction between
the plural news segment or now.
It's certainly need to know whether it's
one person or more than one person.
Do you think it's reasonable for people
that are asexual people that really are
uncomfortable with the idea of being a
man or a woman?
Is it reasonable that we come up with a
distinction for that?
I mean that seems like it would be nice
and this is one of the things that
you've said,
one of the,
one of the things that you don't like
about this,
that you're being compelled to use these
made up pronouns and that if we as a
society,
as a culture,
as a civilization,
sort of adopt a new phrase that you
would.
That one we had transexual were.
Yeah,
but I know.
I know that's problematic because it's
not asexual.
Transexual would be transitioned and
here's the other distinction.
This is another important thing.
Those aren't the people that have the
problem with it.
The people that have the problem with
these pronouns,
the transsexual community almost
entirely,
or at least I shouldn't say entirely,
but predominantly prefer the alternative
pronoun.
A male to female transgender person
prefers to be called a woman or she and
use the female pronouns and male
opponents.
Yes.
Yeah,
so there's some tinies abolition of the
Trans Sexual Community,
or we could say there's some tiny
fraction of people who are identifying
themselves with the transgender
community,
which is already a tiny fraction.
Who claims that they have an identity
that doesn't fit into either binary
category.
Well,
it's a proposition that I think bears
some scrutiny to begin with because I
don't believe that the claims that that
tiny community is making our coherent in
any sense because they say,
well,
you could be man woman or neither or
both.
It's,
it's,
it's those aren't coherent claims in my
estimation,
and if what they're saying is,
if we don't fit into a category and
therefore we get to invent our own
plurality of categories,
it's not logically tenable that isn't
how it works because you get an infinite
number of categories out of that.
And that's what's happening already
online.
One of my favorite stories came out of,
uh,
an all girls university in Massachusetts
where a group of women where they were
trying to pick a president of the
student body or whatever.
And uh,
one of the girls who went to that school
decided that she identified as a man.
So she changed her name and I don't
believe there was any hormones or
anything involved.
I think she just changed her name.
She called herself masculine of center,
Gender Queer,
changed your name to a masculine name,
ran for president of whatever the hell
this is.
I think it was willingly.
Yes,
I believe you're right.
One and then was denounced by the rest
of the class because now she was a white
male.
So she was a part of the patriarchy and
she was a part of the whole problem with
society and that she should not be
allowed or he should not be allowed to
take that position,
which I just,
I.
that's a really good example.
We read it on air and I couldn't stop
laughing.
Right.
Well that's good.
That's a really good example of the
chaos that ensues when you start to blow
apart standard categories.
There's a chaos in between categories
that that's made of a,
of an infinite multiplicity.
That's why you see two with the lgbt
rainbow.
They're getting caught in their own
metaphor.
So there's an infinite number of
gradations in a rainbow and there's an
infinite number of letters that are
accumulating on the lgbt rainbow and
there's an element of clear absurdity to
that.
And one of them is,
I believe it's q plus that includes the
other kin types.
It's like,
well,
the claim is,
I'm marginalized,
and then that sort of becomes
normalized.
And then there's a group right outside
of that that says,
well,
I'm marginalized to.
And another group says,
well,
I'm,
here I am.
I'm also marginalized and there's
absolutely no logic.
Once you've identified yourself as
marginalized,
there's no logical way that you can
exclude anyone else who regard
themselves as marginalized and so the
marginalized,
the,
the community of the marginalized
expands and expands and expands and
expands.
And part of the reason for that is that
people are,
every individual is a multiplicity and
there's an element to every individual
that's marginalized,
you know,
so for example,
it's clearly the case that when a child
is socialized,
there's pros and cons to that.
The pros are the socialization turns the
little beastly two year old into a four
year old that other children can play
with and that that does happen between
the ages of two and four.
If a child is socialized properly,
then then what the child does is kind of
turned into a clone of everyone else so
that he or she can benefit from being
able to interact with everyone else.
Now that that builds up a certain amount
of individuality because kids learn to
talk and they learned to play and all
that,
and it destroys a certain amount of
individuality.
So everybody sacrifices a certain
portion of their peculiarity to become a
socialized creature and some of that's
good and some of it's bad and we know
that that's.
That's the standard story of the
rebellious Adolescent Against Society
for crushing their individuality.
Right?
And there's,
there's some,
there's an element of that that's true,
but by the same token,
if you don't sacrifice a certain amount
of your individuality to the group,
there's no such thing as society.
Everybody has to live on their own.
Everyone is in their own subjective
bubble,
which is of course now required by this
law and society itself breaks down and
so you can't have a society without
marginalizing people or you can't have a
society without making everyone part of
everyone marginalized.
And so then when you start to
concentrate on the marginalized,
it just grows and expands and grows and
expands and grows and expand until
everyone becomes marginalized.
And that just highlights a real problem
with quote mining that is going to take
that you can't have a society without
marginalizing people quote and put it
under Dr Jordan Peterson.
This is what he believes.
Well,
that's actually what Jacques Derrida's
said that the,
the,
the most famous of the postmodernists,
that,
that's why derrick is such a,
uh,
invasive force.
He said,
well,
you can't have a society without
marginalizing.
It's like,
well,
that's true.
It's true comma,
but dot,
dot,
dot.
Right.
But the fact that you can't have a
society without marginalizing doesn't
mean that you shouldn't have a society.
And it doesn't mean that the only reason
that society exists is to marginalize.
And that was at his claim that that's
what makes him so he's absolutely
pathological to the core.
Jacques Derrida,
and,
and apart from his claims that all we do
is trade power games because that's
another one of his claims.
His other claim is that the purpose of
categorization,
the purchase purpose of society is to
marginalize.
And that's absolutely absurd.
The purpose is so that we can all play a
moderately mediocre but productive,
homogenous social game.
Is it perfect?
Well,
obviously not.
Does it require the sacrifice of
individuality?
Yes.
Is some of that sacrificed individuality
valuable?
Absolutely.
What's the alternative?
No society.
While I don't think so,
that doesn't seem like a very good
alternative to me or maybe some sort of
egalitarian utopia.
Well yeah,
we had 100 years of that and 100 million
deaths as a consequence and so maybe not
that either.
What we have right now is a flawed
system,
but it's the best flawed system that
anybody's ever come up with and of
course it marginalizes people.
How could it not?
You know,
if,
if kids organize themselves in a
playground to play hide and go seek,
they've marginalized all the kids that
wanted to play tag obviously,
but that doesn't mean that they
shouldn't come to a consensus and go
ahead and play a game.
At least they're bloody while playing a
game that,
that you know,
pretty much everybody has access to.
I think marginalized is a lot of times
associated with oppression that the term
marginalized
and it's not necessarily the case and I
think that society as a whole and
civilization is sort of a work in
progress.
We're,
we're working all this out and that's
one of the beautiful things about you
being able to discuss these things on
your youtube page as opposed to just
having to battle it out inside the echo
chamber of the universities.
You're able to express this stuff out in
the world where people like me that a 49
years old and aren't in college have a
chance to read this and see like,
wow,
what is this guy going through over
there at the University of Toronto?
And then you start to examine the laws
and you start to look at what's going on
here and this egalitarianism utopia
idea.
It's beautiful and it's concept that we
should all be able to get along and
everything should be equal.
The problem is it defies human nature.
It defies the 200,
300,000
years of DNA that we have bouncing
around inside of our bodies that demand
certain types of behavior and I think
it's so important that we discuss these
things and I think that society and
civilization as a whole,
this,
this thing that is ultimately in this
growing state,
this constant state of improvement.
And,
and,
and objective interaction,
I mean,
there has to be some sort of discussion.
One of the problems that I have with the
soda,
so called Social Justice warriors and
what this movement is that they're in
forcing a certain type of thinking and
behavior and their incredibly aggressive
about it.
Hence the
warrior term.
Yeah.
Well,
I think,
I think a fair bit of that is grounded
again in temperament,
which is quite comical.
I mean,
one of the things that our research
indicated research on political
correctness indicated that his trait,
agreeableness is a good predictor of
holding politically correct views and
also that being female is a good
predictor of holding politically correct
views.
And I think part of the reason for that
and,
and the warrior aspect to it too,
is that agreeableness is a maternal
instinct trait,
roughly speaking.
And you know,
human beings have very powerful maternal
instincts.
That's true for women and for men
because men are very involved.
Male human beings are very involved in
the raising of their children,
which makes them quite different than,
than many large animals.
Um,
on the one hand,
if you're a very maternal,
you're very compassionate and protective
of those that are within your kin
boundary and you can try to include more
people in that if you want.
And,
and that's,
that's the political goal,
but you're unbelievably hostile to
anyone who's outside of that that you
regard as a threat slash predator.
And so agreeableness,
agreeableness makes you divide the world
up into protected children and Predator
and predators
and you see that on social justice
warriors twitter pages.
I mean,
I follow a bunch of them and I go to
them and I watched this ain't incredibly
supportive to ridiculously so in terms
of like many
mediocre expressions tweets,
oh my God,
it's so brilliant.
And it's like you're saying almost
nothing.
There's so incredibly supportive of the
people that think along their lines and
so incredibly hostile.
And this,
uh,
this idea of shaming people that don't
agree with them not interacting with
them,
but almost immediately insulting them,
almost immediately marginalized.
And then,
which is ironic,
this is what you see constantly,
is like super supportive and super
aggressive against people that have any
sort of an opposing viewpoint.
Well,
they're all predators,
the ones that have an opposing viewpoint
and that's how they define them.
It's one of the things that's very
comical about this from my perspective,
is that it's such sex stereotypical
behavior.
Is that at the same time that the social
justice warriors are denouncing,
the idea that,
um,
psychology for example,
might have anything to do with sex
differences.
They're acting out sex stereotype
behavior like mad in terms of their
persecution of predators and their
protection of the,
of the Qin Qin slash ingroup.
So,
and you're,
you are a,
a social psychologist.
No,
no,
I'm not.
I'm a clinical personality psychologist.
And what is the difference?
Well,
one of the differences is that
personality and so and clinical
psychology isn't a corrupt enterprise.
Whereas social psychology fundamentally
is,
it's been going through an absolute
internal revolution over the last two
years because of all,
because of its own discovery that many
of its fundamental studies in
propositions are flawed.
I would say social psychology is the
most social justice slash left leaning
part of psychology and its methods are
generally appalling there.
They're not well documented and they
produce all sorts of categories that
don't exist.
Whereas personality,
I know it seems like it might seem like
trivial distinction to people outside of
the field,
but that these disciplines are quite
separate from a historical perspective.
They developed quite separately.
Personality psychologists are very,
very careful about defining what they
measure.
And so for example,
I studied the big five personality
traits.
That's extroversion,
neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness,
openness,
um,
and under openness falls,
intelligence,
these are very well documented.
We can really measure them,
we can't measure them as well as we
would like to.
We've identified the biological basis
for most of the traits and we understand
a fair bit about how they make people
different.
And um,
and,
and personality psychologists have been
very,
very careful about measurement were
social psychologists are,
as a general rule,
very,
very cavalier about their,
about their concepts.
And that's led to a tremendous
pollution,
I would say,
of the psychological literature.
The implicit association test is a good
example of that.
That's the test that's being used to
assess people's unconscious biases,
unconscious racial biases,
and so for example,
if,
if I showed you a bunch of pictures of
black people in a bunch of photographs
of white people and then I asked you to
associate a good or a bad word with the
black people are the white people to
respond after you've seen the picture.
If you are white and you saw white
photos,
you'd be faster at responding to the to
the positive words and so they've used
that as evidence of racism.
But part of the problem with that is
that you can't distinguish it from a
novelty response.
So I mean most people in a given racial
group are far more familiar with members
of their racial group and the fact that
they're more likely to associate
negative things with racial groups that
are outside of their racial group isn't
something that can be easily
distinguished from just a novelty
effect.
But they make wide ranging claims about
the inbuilt biases in people and also.
And that's lent.
And that's lent a impetus to these
movements that are racing through
corporations across the United States
and governmental agencies where people
are being subjected to mandatory
unconscious racial bias retraining.
And there's no evidence by the way,
that,
that works at all.
In fact,
the evidence that there is suggest quite
the contrary.
I saw this on one of your videos.
Um,
you were,
you were discussing how preposterous
this is on one of your videos because
one of the people that was opposing you
was actually a part of something like
this,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
the human resources and equity people at
the University of Toronto have made
mandatory unconscious racism training,
anti bias training,
and they've made it mandatory for their
staff.
And I found that absolutely appalling.
First of all,
it's political.
It's political reeducation.
So when you say,
but mandatory like this is something
that,
you know,
I didn't have to because I'm not a,
I'm not part of the human resources
staff,
but the people that they're consulting
with to implement these sorts of
programs certainly have faculty and
students in their sites.
I mean,
these are,
these are trial runs for much broader,
uh,
rolling out of exactly this sort of,
of exactly this sort of a reeducation.
What's the methodology behind it and how
has this been,
has been vetted?
Oh,
I don't think it's been vetted at all.
The like if you're going to,
let's say you want to put in,
in,
into practice and educational process,
what you need to do is you need to
measure the initial state validly so
that your measure,
so you need to use multiple measures and
all those measures need to say the same
thing.
So if you're going to accuse someone of
racism,
you need several different measures of
racism and then you have to show that
across all the measures.
So like using different meters,
all the meters should read the same
thing.
Then you have to implement your
educational intervention carefully
defined.
Then you have to,
do,
you have to see afterwards if the
consequence of the educational effort
was a reduction in those initial,
uh,
indices,
those additional measures,
that sort of thing when it's been done
at all,
has showed that educational
interventions of that sort that are
mandatory actually make racism and bias
worse rather than better.
But why let a few facts stop you because
we already know from the postmodernists
that there's no such thing as facts
anyways.
So there's skin Canada here.
Here's something is one of the things
that really makes me proud of my
country.
Our government has now announced that
the judiciary in Canada will be
selected.
If you're going to be a candidate to be
a judge,
you have to produce a dossier that
specifies your,
your identities,
whatever they happen to be racial,
ethnic,
religious,
and then you,
the committee that's going to appoint
you to the judiciary has to have
undergone mandatory anti racism and bias
training before they're allowed to serve
on the committee.
So basically we've set up a situation in
Canada.
Where are the people who select their
judges have to go a kind of
indoctrination that has no validity from
a scientific perspective before they're
allowed to select our judges.
Now who's enforcing this where to
justice minister,
but where justice minister,
where did this program come from?
All sorts of people who have,
who are,
who are offering these programs now and
so we've come a growth industry,
but what is their qualifications?
That's a good question,
right?
Qualifications,
zero browser rains.
Yeah.
Well there's just no way of having
qualifications for doing this sort of
thing because it's not a valid
procedure.
So how does he claim to be qualified?
So they claim to be qualified.
They come to the university and they
say,
I have a solution.
The university says finally just run
with it.
And they just implemented because to
question anything that would absolve.
Racism is racist.
Yes,
right?
Yes.
And they did that in collaboration with
the black liberation collective,
which is police that one because that,
that one's adorable.
The black liberation collective isn't
that?
Isn't that the group that somehow things
that white people are inferior because
they don't have enough melanin,
so it was started by a woman who said
exactly that she's a black supremacist
and she said that the reason that the
reason that white people are inferior
because they don't have enough melanin
in their skin and Melanin apparently is
this agent.
It's obviously it's a pigment,
but it's apparently this agent that
transforms cosmic energy into wisdom
mean she's completely.
You can make.
You can make up your own mind about her.
And then the other person who started
the black liberation collective is a
woman who used to work for the
University of Toronto Students Union who
is now being pursued by that student's
Union for embezzling $300,000
of from,
from,
from that organization with the help of
a couple of her cronies.
Well,
why let a few facts stand in the way of
abolishing racism?
Yeah.
Well,
they also.
They also are perfectly willing to
promote violent means of social
transformation and the university claims
that it's in favor of safety,
you know,
because they've gone after me because my
refusal to use compelled pronouns is
apparently made the campus unsafe,
but they're perfectly willing to take
advice from the black liberation
collective and not only are they willing
to take advice from them and not disavow
them despite their support for violent
means of of social revolution.
They're also pushing equality of outcome
on their employees and the people who
taught there mandatory anti racism and
anti bias training program said outright
in their training material,
which I have copies of that any
institution that doesn't have equality
of outcome as as part of its
characteristic at every level of the
power organization is corrupt and should
be restructured.
But that pales in comparison to my
refusal to use compelled pronouns.
Like obviously don't understand how this
gets so far.
I just don't understand how no one has.
There's no rational thinking involved in
the administration and the and the
people that are implementing these
ideas.
I just don't understand how it gets to
the point where things get too terrible
places.
One tiny step at a time.
You know,
if I encroach I,
if I encroach on you and I'm
sophisticated about it,
I'm going to encroach two millimeters.
I'm going to encroach right to the point
where you start,
start to protest,
then I'm going to stop,
then I'm going to wait.
Then you're going to calm down.
Then I'm going to encroach again,
right to the point where you protest.
Then I'm going to stop,
then I'm going to wait,
and I'm just going to do that forever.
And before you know it,
you're going to be back three miles from
where you started and you'll have done
it one step at a time and then you'll
go,
oh,
how'd I get here?
And the answer was,
well,
I pushed you a little farther than you
should have gone,
and you agreed,
and so then I pushed you a little
farther than you should've gone again.
And you agreed,
and if anybody's interested in this sort
of process,
and this is a horrifying book,
if you want to read about how this
process works,
you can read a book called ordinary men
by Robert Browning in ordinary men is
about browning,
was interested in how the Nazis trained.
They're there,
they're there,
they how they train people to kill
basically.
And so Robert Browning studied this
police battalion.
It's very interesting book.
So these were middle aged German men.
So they,
they were,
they were raised and educated really
before Hitler came to power.
So they weren't indoctrinated Nazis,
they were policemen and when the Nazis
went through Poland and then and then
needed to impose their brand of order on
Poland,
they brought policemen and they brought
this battalion of middle aged policemen
in and they're commandant.
Their commander was by all accounts,
a pretty decent guy.
And he told them that because it was war
time,
they were probably going to have to do
some pretty terrible things,
but that they could go home if they
didn't think they were up to it.
So there was no compulsion.
You know,
this wasn't a milgrim experiment or or
an experiment where you had to obey
orders.
The guy who was giving the artist said,
look,
this is going to be awful,
but you can back off,
but the guys thought,
well,
I'm not going to leave my comrades here
to do the dirty work,
you know,
which is kind of a virtue in in a
perverse way.
And then Browning details how they went
from ordinary policeman to guys who were
taking naked pregnant women out into the
middle of fields and shooting them in
the back of their head and they were
physically ill during most of the
transformation process.
You know,
they started out by what?
Rounding up the Jewish men between the
ages of 16 and 65,
while you know,
you can kind of understand that because
you're at war and then,
well then they put them in stadiums and
then,
well then they had to shoot some of
them.
Then they had to load them on cattle
cars.
It was like one step at a time.
These guys were having a dreadful time
of it.
They didn't stop.
And so that's how things get to where
they are now,
is that,
I mean,
I know they're not at that point and I'm
not trying to make the case that they're
at that point.
Well,
you're one of the first people that
sounding an alarm that there's,
there's a real issue with controlling
people.
There's a real issue with controlling
dialogue,
controlling the way people communicate
and that these ideologies,
although seemingly innocuous,
they can take you down very dangerous
roads.
Yes.
Well,
seemingly innocuous ideology,
those words,
innocuous ideology,
those words do not go together.
There are no innocuous ideologies.
And there are forms of pathological
oversimplification and there are also
clubs.
I mean,
I mean the kind of clubs that you hit
people with as well as the clubs that
you belong to.
The advantage to me being an idiot log
is that I can explain everything.
I can feel morally superior and I know
who my enemies are.
And you know what you're supposed to do
with enemies.
They're not your friends,
right?
You move against them.
And you know,
we're approaching a situation,
and this has already happened,
I think more in the United States than
in Canada,
although our countries are competing to
see who can cross the idiot line
fastest.
You're,
you're in a situation in the US where 50
percent of your population won't talk to
the other 50 percent.
That's not good.
And I would say it's more pronounced on
the left liberal side because they
regard everybody who voted for trump as
essentially as an enemy.
It's like,
hey people,
that's 50 percent of your citizens.
You might think about talking with them.
You know,
people you can't talk to.
Those are enemies.
My ironically,
I really truly believe that one of the
big factors in trump's rise to power is
that people are sick of this
oversimplification in this ridiculous
ideology coming from the left like that.
This combined entity politic.
Exactly.
And so they've chosen an identity
politics that opposes the identity
politics that they think is disgusting.
Yeah.
And that's just starting.
It's just just start.
That's right.
Well,
if you teach,
if you teach one side to play identity
politics,
defacto,
you teach the other side to play
identity politics,
and I've seen more and more people who
are center people as far as I'm
concerned,
pushed to the right because of the
continual insistence that by their mere
existence,
they're part of the perpetrator group
just by being a white person who is
somehow or another successful.
You are a privileged person.
You're part of the elite.
You're part of the one percent.
You're a part of the problem.
Yeah.
You're part of the oppressors.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Or an oppressor by being just to just by
a person with a home in the suburbs.
Well,
and it's also extremely annoying for
people who've worked really hard and
who've made the requisite sacrifices to
become along some
dimension,
to have that immediately attributed to
their oppression and it's not.
It's not obvious that that's something
we want to do.
It's like for the social justice warrior
types out there who might be listening,
it's like,
do you.
Are you really willing to say that every
single person who's accomplished
something as done that as a consequence
of oppression,
that that's again what the Soviets
claimed with regards to the to the
successful peasants in the 19,
in the just before the 19 twenties.
It's like,
well,
the peasants weren't emancipated.
They were serfs until about 30 years
before that they were serfs.
They were basically slaves and some of
them had clambered up to the point where
maybe they could have owned their hot
and a cow and you don't employ somewhat.
While the Soviet claim was,
well,
that's all theft.
You got that all because you're an
oppressor.
And so then the Soviet intellectuals
went into the villages and just imagine
how this happened.
So imagine a village,
small town where everyone knows
everybody and there's maybe 10,
20 people there who are moderately
successful.
Okay?
And so you can imagine that those 20
people have like a 100 enemies at the
bottom of the socioeconomic
distribution.
Useless,
horrible.
People who are jealous and resentful
about the fact that these people have
been successful.
Okay?
So now the intellectuals come in and say
property is theft,
success is oppression,
and then they looked for the people in
the village who are willing to move
against those 20 successful people.
Well those guys at the bottom,
those hundred resentful,
jealous,
murderous people at the bottom there
just waiting for an opportunity to go
kick down some doors.
And that's exactly what they did in the
19 twenties.
And as I said,
they wiped out all their productive
peasants and then 6 million Ukrainian
starve to death.
They had posters.
The Soviets produced posters in the 19
thirties that said essentially,
um,
don't forget it's wrong to eat your
children.
So whoa.
Yeah,
whoa.
There's nothing about the Soviet,
there's nothing that you can imagine
that's horrible enough so that it
matched the reality of what happened in
the Soviet Union between 19,
19 in 1959.
And you know,
the West knew about this too early.
Malcolm Muggeridge in the thirties was
documenting for,
for England,
for,
for English newspapers,
exactly what was going on in the Soviet
Union.
The bloody intellectuals didn't admit it
until the mid seventies,
you know,
with the exception of people like George
Orwell.
So why do these patterns repeat
themselves?
What is it about human beings?
Well,
we like things simple.
We like things simple.
So say you often like a simple
explanation is a good explanation unless
it's too simple.
But distinguishing between simple and
too simple is no easy matter.
We like,
we like to know who's our friend and our
enemy and we liked the feeling of
unearned moral superiority and moral
standard yard.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the challenge.
Especially when there's no such thing as
earning anyways.
So,
and then,
I mean there's deeper and darker things
that are underneath that.
So like the,
the human proclivity to pull down those
who have more than you.
It's like these kids on the campuses who
are claiming identity with the
oppressed,
you know,
somewhere like Yale.
It's like how in the world you can speak
of oppression if you happen to be at
Yale is beyond me.
I mean,
first of all,
your North American,
which puts you in the top one percent,
and then of North Americans,
you're in the top one percent,
the top one percent of one percent,
but yet you want that,
you want to have all the power that goes
along with that and you want to have the
moral superiority that comes from being
a representative of the oppressed.
So that's exactly what you want.
You want all the power and you want all
the victimization at the same time.
Well,
yours.
Yale is a great example because Yale was
one of what happened with the Halloween
costume debacle at gale was one of the
first videos that was released that made
people horrified where they,
they couldn't believe how students were
communicating with professors.
Yeah.
Well,
the student who,
who screamed up a storm about,
about that,
uh,
the male professor who was the husband
of the woman who wrote the Pro Halloween
costume letter,
it turned out she was on the bloody
hiring committee that hired him.
One of the things she screamed was,
who hired you?
It was like,
well,
it turned out it was you because you
were on the committee just a few years
before.
I know,
and they took it like,
yeah,
explain that to people that don't know
what the hell we're talking about.
Well,
the explain this debacle because it
really was about questionable Halloween
costumes.
Well,
it was about questioning Halloween
costumes.
Halloween costumes are a part of the
whole point of Halloween is to have
questionable costumes.
Right.
You play with depth for example,
in decay and and horror and and it's,
it's a time when the norms with regards
to the expression of things that are
outside of our normal behavior are
suspended so that everybody can,
can have a little celebration as it
turns out.
Well,
you know,
campuses have got all upset about things
like cultural appropriation at Queen's
University in Canada just the other week
they were going after students who are
dressing up as Vietcong for example,
or Mexicans.
It's like,
I just don't see what the hell is racist
about dressing up like a Mexican.
Mexicans have a traditional traditional
clothing.
There's nothing wrong with Mexicans,
so why is it wrong?
Just dress up like that.
If you want to be Poncho via for
Halloween,
what's wrong with that?
Oh,
well we'll give you can you can regard
that as an image just as much as a
denigration.
It's like why is that such a problem?
Right.
But anyways,
it doesn't matter because nothing's too
trivial to be a problem to a social
justice warrior and because they don't
like to deal with real problems.
And Yale went after Halloween
costs.
So this woman wrote a letter saying
maybe we should just relax about this
stuff and you know,
and not,
don't put restrictions on what people
wear for Halloween,
but let people decide what is and isn't
offensive.
Yes.
Well in
many Halloween costumes are offensive.
That's the point.
But her letter was in a really
reasonable.
It was perfectly reasonable.
It was like,
it was like an adult wrote it.
Yes.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
all hell broke loose and she ended up.
She ended up quitting and I think he
did.
No,
I don't think.
I don't think he left.
I don't think he left,
but she did.
Seeing him bow down to this woman
screaming at him in his face was so
disturbing.
It was so humiliating.
I felt so humiliated for him because she
was screaming,
this is our home.
What the fuck are you doing?
You're not making it home.
The university's not a home,
right?
It's not a safe space.
It's not a secure space.
None of that.
And,
and if,
if that,
when they get a university isn't a home,
that's not what it is.
It's a place to be confronted by,
I would say often horrible ideas.
You want to learn about history,
you think that's going to be safe.
Do you know what human history is like?
It's an endless blood bath with,
with,
with a certain amount of hopeful
progress underlying it.
It's,
it's a,
it's a horror show and great literature
is like that.
And,
and,
and biology is terrifying and physics is
terrifying and you want to be safe.
It's stay home.
Stay home with your mom,
stay home with your dad.
Don't come to university if you want to
be safe because even go outside.
No,
why don't we have you if you're going.
If the university is going to make you
safe,
then it ceased to be a university,
so one of the things I try to do in my
class,
I have this class called maps of
meaning,
which concentrates on atrocity basically
on Soviet atrocity and and Nazi
atrocities mostly,
and what I try to do in the class is to
teach my students that had they been in
Nazi Germany in the 19 thirties,
they would have been Nazis and had they
been offered the opportunity to be an
Auschwitz,
Auschwitz camp guard than maybe they
would have leapt at it and maybe they
would have been in the sadistic,
in the more sadistic proportion of the
Auschwitz camp guard population.
You think that makes you feel safe.
It doesn't make you feel safe to know
that Nazis were humans and you happen to
be one of them.
So I think that educators that tell
students that they're offering them a
safe space are doing them a profound
disservice.
And you don't.
I'm a clinical psychologist and here's
one of the things you do to make people
less afraid.
You don't make the world safer.
What you do is you people tell you what
they're afraid of and then you break it
into little bits so that they can go
confront them.
You know,
so maybe they afraid of going to a party
and you break that down.
You say,
well,
do you know how to introduce yourself?
And he said,
well,
I know I don't really even know how to
shake someone's hand.
And so then you practice having them
shake their hand and introduce
themselves because maybe they weren't
taught by that by their halfway did
parents,
when they were,
when they were young,
because they were ignored and so then
you say,
well maybe you can go to a party for
half an hour and all you have to do is
introduce yourself to people and we'll
call that success and you build up their
competence
and their confidence one step at a time.
And what happens to the clinical
literature indicates quite clearly is
you don't make people less anxious.
By doing that,
you make them braver.
It's not the same thing.
You don't make the world and its horrors
smaller.
You make the person and their their
their capacity to deal with horror
larger.
You encourage them,
you strengthened them.
Now that's what you do at a university.
You arm people with arguments,
you hone their intellect,
you,
you help them learn to write so they can
marshal their arguments.
You,
you'll help them learn how to engage in
intellectual combat because that's
better than engaging in real combat and
you make them.
You make them hard and strong.
You don't mollycoddle them and make them
safe unless you're their enemy,
unless you're trying to devour their
spirit.
And that's what we have in the
universities we have.
We have the reign of the diploe mother
who's,
who's answered everything is,
Oh,
just come a little closer and I'll
protect you from the world.
It's just like Hansel and Gretel,
the,
you know,
the witch,
and the Hansel and Gretel story.
Well,
my house is made of gingerbread.
Just come in here and everything will be
fine.
While she feeds,
you can need to fatten you up so she can
eat you.
That's the archetype of a modern
university.
When did this start?
When did the trigger warnings,
when did the safe spaces,
when did all this emerge?
Well,
it has its roots in the student
radicalism of the 19 sixties,
especially the far left radical Islam.
It really popped up in the 19 nineties
and the early nineties when I was
teaching in the US at that point and
which university I taught at Harvard
from 93 to 98 and there was a fair push
for political correctness especially in
the early part of the nineties but,
but it,
it got pushed back down and disappeared
and went under ground and went
underground is more accurate and then
it's just come back with a vengeance in
the last five years and I think it's
partly because we have all these radical
left political activists departments at
the universities.
Women's studies being at the top of the
list that have done nothing for the last
30 years to even longer than that.
Now it's almost 40 years,
30 years,
let's say,
have done nothing but producing a never
ending stream of ideological.
He minded counter civilization,
political activists and that's all
subsidized by,
by tuition and by the public purse.
And that's another thing we really got
to ask ourselves is why the hell are we
subsidizing revolution?
Why are we doing that?
It's crazy and it's dangerous.
It's dangerous.
What?
So what exactly is going on with women's
studies that you believe is fostering
revolution?
Well,
you'd go on their websites and read,
read what they say.
I mean,
first of all,
for the,
for the women's studies types,
and this is a,
what would you call it,
a false anthropology.
There's this idea that way back when
there was a feminist paradise,
uh,
and that would be like noble savage mode
of living where everything was
egalitarianism and a women dominated.
It was a matriarchal culture that was
put forward by Ucla anthropologist named
[inaudible].
I can never pronounce her name properly,
but I think I got it.
And then that was overthrown by
patriarchal institutions essentially
starting at about the time say,
of the,
of,
of Judaism.
And that was all overthrown.
And ever since then we've lived in an
oppressive patriarchy.
And that's what our culture is.
It's an oppressive patriarchy.
So they're pointing to one unsuccessful
society that they believe existed or did
it?
No,
no,
it didn't exist.
There's no evidence for whatsoever.
It's,
it's,
it's complicated,
but it's the,
it's the telling of a kind of
psychological myth as if it was history
and,
and anyway.
So,
so the basic claim is that Western
civilization is a brutish patriarchy and
that whatever positive things that
might've managed to accomplish were all
accomplished as a consequence of
oppression and,
and uh,
and theft,
and that the appropriate thing to do is
to restructure it from the bottom up and
they mean that they mean that they mean
every single bloody concept.
And you can marry that with modern
postmodernism and throw in a nice stash
of Marxism and you have the,
the ideological and motivated grounds
for social revolution.
And I'm just go online and look at a
dozen women studies websites.
Just read them.
You can see what they say.
They produce political activists and
error.
A goal is to restructure the patriarchy.
Well,
what's the patriarchy?
While the patriarchy is Western
civilization and what is restructure
mean?
That's easy.
It means tear it down and destroy it.
Why?
Because it's a brutish system that's
predicated on nothing but oppression.
It's nothing but a tyranny in the.
In the eyes of the,
of the radical women's studies types.
Heterosexuality.
That's a tyranny.
Capitalism.
Democracy.
Well,
that doesn't even exist,
and even if it did,
it would be a tyranny.
Everything's a tyranny,
and so you can ask these and what would
they replace it with?
They replace it with their own
ideological utopia.
While we've already had 100 years of
that and we saw what happened.
Oh,
well that doesn't matter.
That wasn't real Marxism.
That's what the bloody marks is.
Always say that wasn't real Marxism.
It's like,
oh,
how many millions of people have to die
before you're convinced that it's real
Marxism and I know what they mean by
that too.
They mean,
hey,
if I was the Marxists dictator,
things would've gone a lot better.
It's like a.
You should think again,
sunshine.
If you were the Marxists dictator,
things wouldn't have gotten a lot
better.
So if you're the sort of person that
thinks that if you would have been
controlled,
things would have gone a lot better than
you're exactly the sort of person who
should never be in control.
So,
and it's resentment.
It's horrible.
Resentment,
you know?
That's an important point because I
think this is something that you've said
that I absolutely agree
with that I think a lot of this thinking
and the way people are behaving,
it seems based on revenge.
It seems based on revenge for awkward
upbringings,
social uncomfortable of
uncomfortability,
that it seems like there's something
about the way they view the world where
they want to get back at people that
have literally done them no wrong.
It's resentment for the burden of being.
It's deeper.
I mean human being human existence is
characterized by a fair bit of
suffering.
You know,
we're limited creatures and life is very
hard.
Everyone dies.
Everyone you love is going to die.
Most of the things you do,
all of the things you do will eventually
fail.
You know,
suffering is a certainty and it's very
easy for people to become resentful
about,
about being,
about existence.
You know,
these kids who shoot up high schools and
and and the,
these mass shooters there,
they're the perfect examples of,
of people who run on nothing but
resentment.
They're out to kill the innocent because
that's the best marker of a.
that's the best way of showing just how
much contempt they have for existence
itself.
Why punish the guilty?
They deserve to be punished.
It's a lot more malevolent and,
and,
and vengeful to punish the innocent.
It's like people are motivated to a
great degree by resentment of being and
a huge chunk of that is manifested in,
out to the dark side of the ideological
possession.
So I get to decide who my enemies are
and then I get to go after them and I
can go after them for every single thing
that's ever been done to me that isn't
good and we'll a lot of that's just
built into the structure of existence.
Then they group up,
they the exhibit confirmation bias.
They all form some sort of a group.
Think and then they act accordingly and
this is what you've been warning against
and this is where I completely agree
with you in this why I think the subject
is so important and I love the way
you've outlined all the steps and the
problems with Marxism and ideologies in
general that we are dealing with this.
These are the beginning steps of it and
people who look at it now and they say
it's social change and social justice.
It's not.
That's right.
This is not going to improve things.
Implementing these policies will make
things worse.
They've made things worse.
Every single place they've ever been
implemented and often they've made
things so much worse that you actually
can't imagine it and people don't do the
reading.
I've done the reading,
I've done the reading.
I know how bad things can get.
They can get so bad that no matter how
bad you think they are,
you're not even in the bloody ballpark.
Well,
it's just so strange that these sort of
courses and these sort of Ida ideologies
are thriving in universities and it's
really disconcerting to someone who has
children.
You know,
that your children are going to go there
and they trade schools.
You know,
I think,
I think that,
wow,
that guy used to teach at Harvard,
just send them to trade schools.
The universities.
I think.
I think
the universities,
I think you can make a reasonable case
that the universities do more harm than
good.
Now I hate to say that.
Well,
this also,
this is a strange time where access to
information is so incredibly easy.
You can get,
you could educate yourself,
right?
Seemingly endlessly online.
Um,
and with books and just,
there's so much information available.
It says not the 19 thirties does,
it's not a time where it was difficult
to get an education outside of the
university the universities may have,
or the university,
which is like the repository of human
wisdom and the attempt to expand that
may have already moved outside the
universities.
You know,
just because an institution calls itself
the university doesn't mean it is.
And many disciplines have turned into
ideological factories and so where's the
university mean?
The university is wherever,
where anyone wants to learn about their
culture and where anyone wants to expand
the domain of human competence.
And a lot of that's happening online
now,
so maybe that's the future.
The only thing the universities have
now,
I think that that people can't get
elsewhere is accreditation,
but they're doing everything they can as
fast as possible to make their
accreditation valueless anyways.
So yeah,
it's really,
it's.
Yeah,
it's a terrible thing to say that the
universities may do more harm than good.
And I haven't come to that conclusion
lightly.
Well,
there's also say it.
I'm sure you do.
There's also a gigantic financial stake.
The amount of money that it will not.
And that's especially the case in the
US.
I mean,
one of the things that's happened over
the last 30 years is that the,
the proportion of university
expenditures that's gone to the
administration has,
has massively,
massively increased.
And at the same time the student loan
burden has increased.
And so what's happened and the weird
senses that the administrators have
conspired to steal the future earnings
of their students and then you can't
declare bankruptcy.
So to me it's indentured servitude,
but you can't declare bankruptcy on
student loan.
You cannot declare bankruptcy on student
loans.
So you think about that.
You tell me what difference there is
between that and indentured servitude.
There's not much because it's the only
thing that I can even think of where
that corporations can go bankrupt.
They do it all the time.
Ken individuals can.
Businesses can fail you.
You can be deemed incompetent or not
capable of paying your debt in every
other case,
but not with universities.
Right?
That's crazy.
It is crazy.
It's crazy because they were just trying
to combat the issue where so many kids
were defaulting on their student loans.
They try to make you perpetually
responsible for it or you know.
The idea is that these kids have to
learn responsibility.
Is that the way to do it?
By overcharging them for some users will
say that it's not a particularly useful
to burden your citizenry with with a
massive debt.
As soon as they graduate at a time when
they're most likely to take
entrepreneurial risks,
yes.
You know you're not going to take
entrepreneurial risks if you're so
burdened with debt,
you can't get yourself off the ground.
Yeah,
and we're talking about hundreds of
thousands
of dollars in debt with people that are.
If you're lucky,
you're going to make what?
Forty,
$50,000
a year straight out of college.
If you're lucky,
so you're dealing with the amount of
money that you would have to make if you
didn't pay any taxes or didn't have any
expenses.
You'd have to work for four or five
years longer than you would actually be
in college to get that degree in the
first place.
It's insane.
Alright.
Would you say to,
to the university students are
listening,
like a lot of your professors are
Marxists.
Ask them,
ask them if they're Marxists.
Read the Gulag archipelago first because
you need to get your arguments together
and nobody and won a Nobel prize for
that book and for his other writing and
it was one of the.
One of the key.
There was a couple of things that
brought down the Soviet Union,
but one of them was Alexander
Solzhenitsyn's book and he demolished
the intellectual credibility of of
Marxism forever,
but you have to read the damn book and
you got to get your arguments in order
to go after your Marxist professors ask
them difficult book to read,
a very difficult book to read.
It's a very difficult book,
although it's difficult because it's so
horrifying.
It's not difficult,
particularly because it's impenetrable.
It's in fact,
it's an absolutely fascinating book in,
in,
in the same way that at that it's
terrible.
Horror story is fascinating,
but.
But there's no excuse for this.
There's no excuse for these.
These professors who,
who claim who claimed to be benevolent
Marxist.
So I think the way you framed it is very
important.
I think the way you framed it as them
being compassionate intellectuals that
are inclined toward this,
because on the surface it seems like
it's what a compassionate intellectual
would would support.
Yeah.
And it's the unthinking adherence to
compassion as the highest moral virtue.
And it's also whenever you have an
ideology,
whenever you have these rigid
established forms of communication or
methods of thinking,
ew,
box people in your box,
people,
then you control them and you get them
to stick inside that ideology.
And in doing so,
you suppress people.
It's so ironic that the people that are
against suppressing are actually
suppressing people through enforcing
these ideologies and suppressing the
marketplace of free ideas.
You're not allowed to have free ideas.
You're not allowed to debate these
things.
I mean,
I've seen.
There was that really famous instance at
the University of Toronto where there's
one guy,
I don't even remember what it barrel.
Yes.
What was his more?
Yeah,
why men make.
Yeah.
It was a multivariate analysis of the,
of the income disparity between men and
women.
He used to be a feminist activist.
He decided to go look into the claim
that women were making.
I think at the time it was seventy cents
for every dollar that men were making.
He thought,
well,
I have daughters.
I better go check this out and see,
you know,
do a little bit of indepth
investigating.
And what he found out was that there
were many reasons for the disparity and
perhaps one of them was unfair
discrimination,
but there were another dozen and they
seem to account more of the disparity
than the discrimination.
I mean,
just the fact that men take the more
dangerous jobs is a,
is a huge contributor to that.
And it's not trivial.
You should get paid more if you're
putting your limbs on the line,
you know,
I mean,
are you grew up in northern Alberta
where were,
were a lot of young men dropped out of
school and went and worked on the oil
rigs.
It's like you go try that.
Well maybe you could do it,
but you know,
the guys would lose their fingers.
They'd lose their toes.
They was 40 bloody below up there and
they'd be wrestling pipe in the middle
of the bush.
I have a friend who does it.
I have a friend who does that in
northern Alberta.
Horrific it is.
It's tough work,
man.
And you're out in the Bush for two weeks
and when you go outside,
there's temperatures where you literally
can't be outside of your truck for more
than 30 minutes.
Right?
You have to jump back in the truck.
And that was called life where I grew
up.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Those are very difficult jobs and
they're very high pain because people
die.
Hard work.
And there's not a lot of women taking
those jobs.
No.
And,
and,
and a good thing too.
So this guy,
um,
I'm sorry,
what is his name again?
Warren Farrell,
who wrote this book was giving a speech
about this book and it was,
the response was so unbelievably violent
and crazy and aggressive and also
ignorant,
ignorant to what he was saying,
ignorant and not,
not wanting to debate the facts but
wanting to call him a massage,
misogynist,
wanting to call this a hate speech.
And that's a favorite man.
Already accused of that twice in the
last two months because I don't want to
use these compelled pronouns.
Just like the one woman in the debate
that you had with the other man that I
believe is transsexual.
Yeah.
The one woman who was trying to say what
is the difference between not using
those words and using racial slurs and
hate speech to to describe these people
like the idea,
just the idea that that's a woman who is
a professor who's expressing it in that
way.
What is the difference between not
choosing to use made up pronouns versus
calling someone a generally accepted
racial slurs that they're trying to
frame that as the same thing.
The racial intellectually dishonest to
the racial slurs are also legal.
So what's happening is the law is
already there is already such that not
using one of these made up pronouns is a
crime.
Whereas using a racial epithet isn't.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So you could use the n word.
No,
it's legally to.
Yes,
but you can't use you,
can't you?
You can have zero.
He's have to say aZ who.
Wow,
this is crazy.
This is really crazy.
This is a bizarre moment in time.
Whereas Bizarre postural nature of it is
so undeniable that it's forcing a lot of
people and I,
I applaud you for doing what you're
doing
and risking your,
your,
your status with the university,
risking your support of your peers and
sticking your neck out the way you've
been doing with your youtube videos
because if you hadn't done that,
there's a lot of people who wouldn't be
aware of how insidious and what you were
describing earlier.
The creep is slow creep towards pushing
forward,
waiting for you to object waiting and
then moving forward a little bit more
and once you relax.
Yup.
Because that's what this is.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's been,
it's been bizarre.
I can tell you that.
I mean my son and I counted the number
of press articles that have been devoted
to this.
These are serious press articles.
This doesn't count youtube or radio or
TV or any of those things.
I mean the youtube coverage has been,
I would say overwhelming.
There's been 170 major press articles
written about those videos in the last
two months.
And what's the general consensus are,
I mean,
are they going to begin with
to begin with?
And the first two weeks,
which was the most stressful part of
this for me,
I would say,
um,
I would say the bulk of the,
of the press articles were,
were,
um,
ran contrary to my views and their basic
theme was something like,
why doesn't the mean professor just play
Nice?
It was something like that.
But,
but luckily,
fortunately I seem to maneuver past
that.
And then people started to actually read
the,
uh,
the policies that I was speaking about
and started to think about them.
And one thing about the press is that
they're actually fairly in favor of free
expression given that that's their
absolute bread and butter.
And so the,
the,
the tenor shifted and I would say the
overwhelming majority of press articles
in the La sueur apart from the first two
weeks have been,
have been positive.
Well,
that's great.
The
what you've done in your youtube videos,
which I think is an amazing forum,
particularly for what you're doing,
is document and describe in great detail
the issues with every single one of
these problems with no interruption and
I think that's one of the best things
about it.
The fact that there's not really a whole
lot of forums that will give you the
chance to express yourself.
I've seen some of your videos have
hundreds of thousands of views and
there's not a whole lot of forums where
you can do that and speak for A.
I mean they're all like an hour long.
Right?
I know,
I know.
I mean it's.
It's amazing.
Youtube is.
Well,
I started,
I posted,
started posting my lectures on Youtube,
my classroom lectures in 2013 and in
really bare bones form.
They're just an ipad recording of me
lecturing.
I didn't edit in the slides of the
images partly because that's very time
consuming,
but then I watched it for about two
years and by September of this year it
declined to about a million views.
And then I really started thinking about
youtube because youtube was cute cat
videos,
you know,
Justin bieber songs for a very long
period of time,
but it's not that anymore and that's
probably been about two years or maybe
two and a half years.
But then I realized that Youtube is
actually a revolution that's as,
as overwhelming as the Gutenberg press
revolution.
Gutenberg invented the printing press
and because for the first time in human
history,
a lecture can have the same reach and
the same longevity as a book and it's a
lot easier for people to listen and that
the time lag publication is basically
zero,
right?
I mean because you can do it live I
guess as we are right now or you can
post it in a day or two after publishing
it and,
and you have access to this insanely
large audience.
And the other thing that's really
interesting about youtube with regards
to my,
especially the more academic videos,
is there's only one reason that people
are watching them.
One,
it's not the production quality.
The audio is okay and I'm a good
speaker,
but it's not the production quality.
The reason they're watching them is
because they want to know and that's
something that's really cool about
youtube and youtube also seems to be
quite skeptical about advanced
production values.
You know,
the people who are,
who are popular are often people like
you who are basically sitting there
talking and everyone's listening.
It's like,
oh,
well people are actually talking about
something and this turns out to be
interesting.
It's like the rebirth of genuine
journalism.
So yeah,
youtube is a,
God only knows what youtube is,
but.
Well,
I think it's international revolution.
I believe you're right.
And I think the Internet in general is
this really new thing in terms of the
ability to express yourself.
I mean it's only existed for 20 plus
years and in terms of human history,
that's a blink of an eye and it's only
really been used as you,
you've described over the last couple of
years in this form.
And I think,
uh,
it also is responsible,
I think for a great deal of the rise of
the popularity of the social justice
movement.
I think it's a double edge sword.
I think these echo chambers and these
people that do find these patterns of
behavior that they subscribe to,
and I think that is part of the problem
with ideologies in general is that
instead of thinking for yourself,
you subscribe to a predetermined pattern
or behavior and you will lock in like,
this is what I'm supposed to believe.
This is what I'm supposed to enforce.
This is what I'm supposed to side with,
and you go with that.
One of the good things about the
internet is that it is potentially
possible to see contrary viewpoints and
analyze them in the comfort of your own
home and being by yourself and and
looking at maybe one of your videos and
maybe someone come to you and I'm sure a
lot have come to your videos in anger,
mad at you,
and then listen to your points of view
and listen to how clearly you've
established all of these positions and
what what you actually feel is the
problem with these positions.
In a very,
very calm and very rational and a very
well educated point of view.
I think the these people,
they have the potential to be at least
informed it because you're the.
I've had lots of,
I've had lots of letters maybe,
I don't know,
2,500
letters maybe to my,
to my email accounts now about this and
a very large number of them,
maybe maybe 200 letters,
150 to 200 have been from people on the
radical left who've written to me and
said that they can no longer speak
because the authoritarian types,
the PC authoritarians have got.
So controlling that there once
fashionable position is now been deemed
unacceptable and they,
they're alienated and it excluded.
I mean,
you see that happening with feminists
like Jermaine greer.
I mean Jermaine greer who's been banned
from campuses,
um,
she's not very happy with the idea that
being a woman is something that's been
reduced to a whim,
right?
Because she thinks that there's more to
being a woman than mirror subjective
choice.
While that's no longer a tenable
viewpoint on the left.
And so people who hold that view point,
many of them are feminists,
are no longer getting along with the say
radical gender bender,
activist types who've who've got center
stage at the moment.
So
yeah,
Christine Summers has the same issue
with that.
She's a feminist and she calls herself
the factual feminist and she pushes back
against and what her perspective is is
instead of embracing these false
narratives and running with them as if
they're the facts and and and just using
that to reinforce your ideology.
She saying that does feminism a
disservice?
Let's look at the actual reality of the
situation and let's look at it from a
balanced and objective perspective and
she gets so much hate for them.
The idea of being rational and
objective.
Well that that's because as far as the
postmodern social justice warriors are
concerned,
those are just code words for
oppression.
There's no object.
You've got to remember this with regards
to having these sorts of arguments.
When you say objective and rational,
that's predicated on your implicit
belief that there is such a thing as the
objective and there is such a thing as
rational.
And the radical postmodernists,
they do not buy that.
Not at all,
not at all.
As far as they're concerned.
That's just another power game on your
part.
And Bill built into the laws like bill
[inaudible] in Canada now in the same,
in the laws in New York City that
governed the use of these gender
pronouns built into the law is the idea
that there's no biological a foundation
for your identity and that it's all
purely subjective.
They built that into the law,
no objective reality,
no biology that's going to unfold over
the next 20 years
or not.
I mean,
isn't it,
isn't it possible that these kinds of
discussions and that your videos and
then all the people that agree and all
the people that are pushing back against
this can have some sort of an effect on
this movement
I think?
Or do you think to say yes?
I mean,
are you cynical about the future?
No,
no,
no.
I'm not at all cynical about the future.
I am cynical about my ability to predict
the future.
Like when I was younger,
much younger back in the 19 eighties.
I mean,
I was very,
very concerned about the possibility of
nuclear war,
but by a,
by yes,
as we all were.
Yes.
By bought about,
by about the mid nineties though,
I realized that things were in such a
state of chaotic flux that the one thing
I can be certain of was that no matter
what I was afraid of with regards to the
future,
that isn't what was going to happen and
so I'm not cynical about the future,
but I do believe that we're in an
unprecedented state of indeterminate
indeterminacy and flux and God only
knows what could happen.
I'm not having said that.
I wouldn't say I'm optimistic about the
possibility that the universities will
reform themselves because I think that.
Well,
even with the free speech debate that
that the University of Toronto hosted,
they did three politically correct
things during the debate,
which,
which I thought was really interesting
because if I would have staged a debate
and been working on their side,
let's say,
I would have said strategically
speaking,
no politically correct maneuvering
during this debate because all it's
gonna do is discredit us,
but that isn't what happened.
The university opened up by noting that
the land on which we were having the
debate was once the.
What was one's property owned by the
original native set native Americans,
which is something I find it boring
because on the one hand we took it and
now on the other hand we want to be
friends.
It's like that's.
I don't think you get to have both sides
of that moral play at the same time,
but that's okay.
That's how the university opened the
debate and then the next thing that
happened was that they announced that
there would be counselors waiting
outside for anybody who was too
traumatized by the contents of the
discussion and then they closed.
They closed by announcing the Trans Day
of remembrance,
you know,
and but,
and the reason I'm pointing this out is
because it,
it just shows you the fact that those
things happened.
They weren't even strategic.
That's just how things are at the
university and they didn't even notice
that people were going to turn
themselves inside out.
Noticing that saying,
well God,
this is so biased.
I can hardly believe it,
which is exactly what happened.
That's how saturated the universities
are with this kind of thinking and I
don't have any idea what can reverse
that collective decisions on the part of
citizens a to stop sending their
children there be to stop donating money
and leaving it in wills and see to
pressure politicians like in my wilder
moments,
I think cut the funding to the
universities by 25 percent and let the
faculty have a war about what's
important and maybe what would be
leftover with what the university should
be.
But I really think it's,
with the exception of the science,
technology,
engineering and mathematics ends of
things.
I think it's come to that.
Don't you think that what you're doing
when you're making these videos is in a
sense branching out a way from just a
university and teaching online because
you all,
like I said,
I think that that you could make a case
that that's where the university is
because that's where people are going
just to get knowledge.
They have no other,
they have no other motivation
and this is a new thing obviously,
but at one point in time,
so it was the printing press,
right?
And this,
this,
this new ability to disseminate
information seems to me to be more
effective,
more accessible,
more reasonable.
Yeah,
and it's entirely possible that what
we're looking at is the future of
kg.
It could be,
it could be.
I mean I've just been spending a lot of
time in the last month or so also
concentrating on video editing and so I
spent about 10 hours this week video
editing about an hour,
a discussion with a Russian Orthodox
icon carver.
Weirdly enough that I'm going to launch
in the next three or four days and it,
it,
we,
we discussed things that,
that are very image heavy and so I've
been cutting in a lot of images and it
is a technology that far supersedes what
I mean.
I like lecturing and lecturing.
Lectures can be very effective,
but basically with youtube you can turn
your lecture into a documentary and then
instead of teaching 100 people you can
teach 50,000.
It's like that's a lot different.
That's a lot different and it's up there
permanently.
Yes.
And that 50,000
can grow and grow and grow and as it
becomes more spread and shared,
the also the discussions about it become
more varied.
Yup.
Well three more than 3 million people
have watched some element of this in the
last couple of months and in September I
had about 9,000
subscribers.
That took me about two years,
three years to build.
And one of my ambitions,
which was kind of a tongue and cheek and
comical ambition is I thought,
hey,
you know,
I bet I can get more subscribers in the
next three years.
Then the UFT has students.
I thought,
well that's pretty interesting,
is like all of a sudden I could have a
body of students,
let's say that's larger than the entire
university's like what?
We'll just exactly what the hell does
that mean?
And the answer to that is,
I don't know what that means.
Who knows what that means,
but one of the other perverse things
that happened while I was being warned
and a cautioned by the university was
that my subscriber base grew from 9,000
to $65,000.
So now I have more youtube subscribers
than the University of Toronto has
students.
It's like,
so then I think,
well hell,
you know,
I could do a whole series on
Solzhenitsyn.
I could do a whole series on George
Orwell.
I could do a whole series on the Aldous
Huxley.
I could do a whole series on archetipal
biblical stories and half of me thinks,
well,
if 50,000
people are going to watch each of those
and I can turn them into documentaries
instead of just lectures.
Maybe that's what I should be doing.
Like I couldn't write a book with that
much reach.
That's crazy.
Reach crazy.
Yeah,
it's,
it's revolutionary.
I believe that.
I believe it's revolutionary.
I believe it is too.
And I believe no one saw it coming and I
think it's such a new thing that we're
all just sort of starting to get a
handle on how to it and what it's
capable of.
Yes.
Well it was like the Internet was for
pornography.
Well that changed quick and youtube was
for cute cat videos and that changed
quick too.
You don't know what the technology is
going to do.
Well it's also a,
I don't know how much you've paid
attention to virtual reality or how much
you've experimented with it,
but my good friend Duncan trussell has
one of those htc vives and uh,
I put it on over his house.
He runs a podcast and we,
we played with it for about an hour and
a half and then we did a podcast and I
am thoroughly convinced,
especially now with a new phones,
there's a phone that I just got called
the Google Pixel and it comes.
You can buy it with this headset,
you slide the phone into the headset,
you put on this virtual reality a
program and you're watching a virtual
reality show on your phone,
a regular phone that fits in your
pocket,
just slides to the headset.
You could do not just a two dimensional
thing where you're showing a lecture and
showing images and having a discussion
and putting these images in the
background.
We're in the foreground and have the
audio over it,
but rather you could have three
dimensional things where you could show
a city of village a mountain range.
You could show a geometric patterns you
could get involved in.
I mean it could be used for a million
different things and not just for
entertainment but also for education and
I think that is,
that's the next step I think.
I mean it's a.
it's an unbelievably fascinating new.
Well,
you must be.
Must be shocked to some degree at how
popular your podcasts have become.
I mean,
you have,
I don't know how many people on Youtube
have larger subscriber base than you,
but it's not that many.
So I mean,
how.
How do you account for that and does
that surprise you?
It's surprising,
but it's that this whole,
this whole podcast thing is very
surprising,
but it's um,
the youtube is only a small fraction of
the amount of people that actually
listen to the podcast.
The numbers of the downloads are insane.
Jamie,
what was the last month's numbers?
Was the youtube was around 12 million
for the month and audio is at $60.
Million.
Wow.
Yeah.
I haven't done,
like,
I haven't played vr anywhere near enough
with turning my online lectures into
podcasts.
He's definitely should.
You definitely should.
It's,
I mean,
a lot of it you could listen to when
you're in a car or when you're
exercising or that sort of thing.
Yeah.
No,
I know.
Glued to a screen with the podcasts.
No,
I was doing some work around my office
when I was listening to one of yours,
one of one of your things on youtube and
I found that it was just as interesting
if I was doing some other things around
my office.
It's a very good passive,
like podcasts themselves are very good
passive form of income.
Yes,
absolutely entertainment that makes them
different than reading because reading
is faster if you're a good reader,
but you can't do anything else while
you're doing it.
Right.
People are much more naturally attuned
to listening than they are to read it
because we've only been reading really
human beings have only been reading
roughly speaking in any large numbers
for hundred years.
Right.
It's a blink of the eye.
Whereas we'd been listening for a very,
very long period of time and all this
new technology like puts us right back.
It puts us back into tribal mode
basically,
except with this incredible
technological enhancement.
It wouldn't be difficult at all to
extract the audio from any of these
youtube videos and just start putting it
online as a podcast and again,
you know,
people could listen to it when they're
in traffic,
when they can't look at it.
Anything on planes,
I'm on the bus or wherever you are,
where you can just sit down and you.
You can close your eyes and you don't
have to be paying attention to it
visually.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
about four or five months ago,
I emailed the university,
the University of Toronto because they
have a kind of a massive online course
branch,
which they're toying with and I said,
look,
I've got a million people who've watched
my videos,
like maybe you guys should give me a
hand.
We should do something about this
because I got a million people who are
watching these videos.
It's like that's,
that's a significant number of people.
It's worth attending to,
but perhaps I contacted the wrong people
but I never did get a response,
but it's something I'm.
While I'm doing it actively right now
and I think the quality of my videos has
improved substantially in the last month
and I really liked doing the video
editing.
Although it's very painstaking,
but it's definitely the universities
better be careful because they're
dumping their content online as fast as
they can.
They're going to make themselves
completely superfluous and some smart
person.
I've been thinking about this for 20
years is going to take over the
accreditation end because you know all
you'd have to do is set up a series of
well designed examinations online and
only let a minority of people pass.
You have instant accreditation
credibility.
It's like here's an entire three years
worth of psychology courses.
Here's the exams.
You take them.
Only 15 percent of the people pass.
Why only 15 percent.
Why would you limit the number because
it makes the accreditation valuable,
but you would limit the number based on
what if you had a much larger group than
15 percent that were effectively
absorbing the information that you did?
Well,
fair enough.
You'd have to.
You'd have to toy with a.
you'd have to toy with the accreditation
mechanisms,
but I mean part of part of the utility
and the accreditation is that it's
inequality.
If everyone gets accredited then the
accreditation is worth noting.
They just make it difficult because
that's what you do is make a difficult.
Yeah,
but I mean instead of limiting
difficulty.
Okay,
so you wouldn't necessarily be limiting
the number.
You would just make it so difficult that
the number would be limited,
almost match.
That's right.
Well,
I think I'd probably make it.
I'd probably live.
Yes,
that's exactly right.
I wouldn't limit the number of times
people could take the exams.
That's a great idea as well.
So as long as you hit threshold,
I mean that's what happens often.
Say with,
with uh,
like if you're trying to trying to pass
the bar or something like that,
you get to take it a number of times,
but you have to,
you have to hit threshold.
Well,
Thaddeus Russell,
who,
who's a history professor at Occidental,
he,
um,
he's doing that very same thing.
He talked about it here that he's
building right now,
an online university and he is planning
on giving out degrees in history through
his online university because he's been
teaching at universities for a long time
and he has a huge problem also with the
politically correct movement.
And he was speaking out against a,
this really crazy story where these two
kids,
uh,
adults got intoxicated and had sex.
And because they were both intoxicated
for some reason,
the boy was described as the attacker
and was a,
he was being accused of sexual assault
and even though it was consensual,
completely consensual,
even though they were both,
not only did she send him,
she sent him texts saying,
do you have condoms?
Come on over,
we're going to do this.
But he,
because they were intoxicated,
he was the one that was the rapist,
which is insane.
It's sexist.
It's 100 percent sexist though,
that that kid is suing,
you know,
and that ace Russell came on here and
discussed it,
but that politically correct ideology
where it's,
it's essentially it's prejudice against
men in that particular theory.
The idea that he's stepping outside of
the university.
I slowly moved.
It means God gets sod is doing that
exactly it to yes.
And you know,
he gets 100,000
people watching is v each video.
Yeah.
He's been out here a few times.
I love that guy.
And again,
he's another one who like yourself,
has stuck his neck out and spoke out
about what he thinks is this
preposterous movement towards denying
facts,
denying reality and forming these
narratives that are based on their
ideologies and,
and sticking within this box and then
seeking to find people that agree with
it and then reinforcing these ideas in
this echo chamber.
And it's just,
it's for someone who's outside of it
like myself.
It's a fascinating thing to watch for
someone who's inside of it like
yourself,
it must be maddening.
Well,
we've tried to.
We've tried other online interventions
too,
so I have these youtube videos up,
but we also designed.
I work with some corporations a while
back because I've done some consulting
and I had designed tests to help people
hire better employees,
which I still do.
And in fact I worked with his company up
in,
in California called the founder
institute and it's the world's largest
stage early technology company
incubator.
It's created 2,500
companies in the last four years and we
test now in 135 cities.
But when I was marketing these tests to
companies,
they kept asking me what could be done
about their poorer performing employees,
and I said,
well,
I didn't know because it's not that easy
to.
If you have someone who's problematic,
who's troubled,
it's not that easy for a manager to
figure out how to straighten them out
and they just don't have the time.
They don't have the time,
they don't have the manpower,
they don't have the training usually to
do that.
But I designed this set of programs
called the self authoring suite,
and one of them,
the future authoring program helps
people write out a plan for their life.
So it helps them to ask you some
questions about six dimensions of your
life.
You know,
your,
your health,
mental and physical,
your use of drugs and alcohol,
your wishes three to five years down the
road for intimate relationships,
for family,
for career,
for education and so on.
It asks you,
what could your life be like three to
five years down the road?
If you set it up for you,
like you were someone you were taking
care of.
So it asks you those six questions,
then it asks you to write for 15 minutes
about about your vision for your life.
You get to have what you want and what
would be good for you,
what would that be?
And then it asks you to write for 15
minutes about what your life would be
like three to five years down the road.
If you let your bad habits and you're,
you know,
idiocies in your foolishness is in your
weaknesses.
Take the upper hand in,
Auger you into the ground because
everyone knows about that.
And so it's like you get to design a
little heaven to strive for and little
hell to avoid and then you write for.
Then you basically turn that into an
implementable plan.
That's the second part of the program.
We've used that with about 5,005
to 7,000
university students now mostly in Europe
at the Rotterdam School of management.
And we've raised their grade point
average of their kids.
Twenty five percent drop their dropout
rate the same and it's had a walloping
effect on men and on non Western ethnic
minorities,
it's moved the Non Western ethnic
minority student population performance
at Rotterdam,
School of Management from 70 percent
below the,
the average to above the female Dutch,
uh,
natives.
And so the other,
the reason I'm telling you this in part
from the fact that it's a very good
program,
and um,
we did it at Mohawk college in Canada a
year ago and we dropped their dropout
rate in the first semester,
50 percent and that especially again
worked well for men because men are at
more risk of dropping out now and,
and,
and especially for men who didn't have
good grades in high school.
So not only is there the possibility for
the net to provide tremendous
dissemination of intellectual material,
but there's also the possibility for the
net to provide dissemination of
psychological interventions that have
major impacts on people's mental health
and productivity at almost at
extraordinarily low cost.
So that's really been fun too.
So I think providing some that sort of a
structure and a framework,
giving people the tools just inform of
asking them questions.
What would you like to do is describe
this,
what is your view and when you do that,
you sort of allow them to help
themselves outline what they would like
to accomplish,
which most people don't do well in our
education system,
our education system was designed in
Chicago in the late 18 hundreds to
produce factory workers because it was
set up when when rural people were
migrating to the cities on mass because
their kids,
first of all,
we're likely to get factory jobs and
second of all,
if you were working in factory,
your kids needed to be taken care of and
so the purpose of the schools was to
train factory workers,
which is why everyone's lined up enrolls
rose and why there are bells.
It's a factory model.
The problem with that is that now
people's careers basically have to be
self determined,
but that's never.
That's never part of the education
system.
Part of the reason I developed these
programs was because I realized this is
the same course where I'm teaching
students that if they would have been in
Germany in the 19 thirties,
they would have be Nazis.
I'm trying to get them to design their
lives and it's way better to have
someone articulate their own plan.
You actually neurologically rewire
people by having them formulate their
own thoughts,
which is why you know your school
teachers used to say,
put it in your own words.
It's actually very good advice.
If they would explain what that means.
It's like if you have to conjure up the
thoughts and you have to articulate
them,
then they change you and so well,
and so this program has had the,
the,
the effects have been absolutely
overwhelming for us as researchers
because it's very,
very difficult to produce an
intervention that actually has a
positive effect on people you know,
you hope it does,
but generally when you test it out,
it's like,
no,
it doesn't do what you thought it did.
Or sometimes it even has the reverse
effect.
That sounds fascinating.
Now,
how do people have had,
can someone,
a regular person have access to this?
It's called self authoring.
So that's e l,
f authoring,
like,
like writing a book,
self authoring Dotcom and the programs I
gave away the future authoring program.
I think it might still be free.
Um,
it was,
yeah,
it is until the end of November I did a
video called message to millennials were
because one of the things Jonathan Heit
said about,
uh,
he called Karl Marx,
the patron saint of the social justice
warriors and John Stuart Mill,
that patron saint of people say who
stood for objective truth and freedom of
expression.
And I thought that was really smart.
He said Brown university is number one
for social justice warrior universities
in Chicago for Truth Universities.
But one of the things that marks has
over John Stuart mill is that mark's is
a social revolutionary and young people
like to think about ways to change the
world.
Right?
And that's actually a positive part of
their development.
It's a stage that the developmental
psychologist,
Sean Piaget called the messianic stage
and he associated that with late
adolescents.
So like while young people want to
change the world,
the problem is,
is that that's been harnessed into
attempts to change other people,
but that isn't what you should do if you
want to change the world,
you should change yourself.
And I don't mean that in some cliched
sense.
I mean it in the sense that Aleksandr
Solzhenitsyn said when he analyzed the
Soviet Union,
he said,
don't be thinking that the line that
divides good from evil runs down
political spectrum or,
or,
or countries or something like that.
It runs down right down the middle of
your soul.
And if you want to sort out the world
and what you do is you sort yourself
out.
It's a serious business,
right?
They say it's more difficult to rule
yourself than to rule a city.
And that's the truth because you're a
complicated and there are horrible
monsters inside of you that need to be
tamed and to,
and to be brought and to be brought into
alignment and submission so that you can
be a powerful and useful person.
And um,
I gave away the future authoring program
as part of this video I made suggesting
to millennials that instead of rushing
out there to change the world by
changing other bad people that they
should look inward and sort themselves
out properly.
And I think we've given away about four
or 5,000
of those programs so far now free till
the end of November.
And then what happens with it?
It's,
well the self or the future authoring
program is regularly $14,
ninety five cents.
And the whole self authoring suite which
involves,
it's a program that helps you write an
autobiography.
So it helps you sort out things about
your past that are still burdening you.
You can tell a if,
if you have a memory that's more than 18
months old approximately,
and when you pull that memory up to
mind,
if you still have an emotional reaction,
that means you haven't fully articulated
the memory,
you haven't analyzed it causally,
you haven't,
you haven't freed yourself from its
grasp and you're carrying it like a
weight and your brain responds to that.
Like the more have more weight you're
carrying like that more baggage.
Let's say the more of the stress Hormone
Cortisol your brain produces and
cortisol makes you old.
Some of this work has been done by James
Pennebaker at the University of Texas at
Austin because he.
He started to pioneer these sorts of
writing programs and he found that if
people wrote about uncertain things
past,
present or future so they could be
traumatic things,
they could be uncertain,
things that their physical health
improved and he.
He did a lot of detailed research trying
to figure out why that was and basically
came down to the explanation that it was
something like an uncertainty reduction
mechanism at work because your brain is
always figuring out how well situated
are you in the world.
How much do you not know compared to how
much have you mastered?
And you can tell that you've mastered
things because when you go somewhere and
you act things turn out the way you want
them.
That's an indication of mastery and your
brain is sort of keeping track across
your whole life of how many places
you've been,
where things haven't worked out compared
to how many places you have been,
where they have worked out,
and if all those places in your past
where things haven't worked out,
you need to map and master and that that
decreases the existential load on you,
but that actually decreases your
psychophysiological load.
It makes you healthier.
It makes you less stress,
and so we've put all that together in
this self authoring suite to help people
write about their past,
to sort it out in a.
In a detailed autobiography.
It asks you questions about your past.
It says,
divide your life up into six epochs and
then divide each of those.
That might be,
say,
oh,
birth to kindergarten and then maybe
elementary school and then maybe junior
high school,
however you want to do it,
and then to write about the emotionally
significant events in each of those
epochs and then to describe their
effects on you and then to analyze how
you did in those situations.
What you might have done differently.
What you might do differently in the
future to straighten out your past,
and I've done that with my students in
my maps of meaning class for about the
last 10 years and some people have
written 15,000
words.
It's not that uncommon for students to
write 15,000
words and their autobiography.
Wow.
So that's such great advice.
That's such great advice about
reconciling with your past because so
many people just carry it around.
Yeah.
Well,
if you're.
If you're thinking about your past,
what it means is you haven't analyzed
the causal chains because you might say,
well,
why do you remember your past?
While you might say,
well,
it's in order to have an objective,
you know,
record of the past.
It's like it has nothing to do with
that.
There's only one reason you remember the
past and that's to be prepared for the
future.
That's why you remember the past.
And so what you're supposed to do is
take the past and extract out from it.
Wisdom and wisdom is the ability to
avoid stumbling blindly into ditches.
And so you think,
well,
here's a time in my past.
I stumbled blindly into this horrible
ditch and terrible things happened to
me.
It's like,
okay,
you need to take that apart.
You need to figure out how was it that
that events conspired with your
participation voluntarily or
involuntarily so that that terrible
consequences merged.
You need to know why that happened and
how you could react differently in that
situation,
and as soon as you do that,
your brain will leave it alone.
You won't obsess you about it anymore
because the anxiety producing parts of
your brain are basically trying to tell
you where there are obstacles in your
environment.
It's like,
look out.
Don't go there.
It's like,
well,
don't go there.
There's fire.
Well,
maybe you could master the fire,
right?
Then you're a wielder of fire.
You're not just a victim and lots of
situations are dangerous or not
dangerous depending on your level of
mastery,
right?
Life is like that,
and so a negative emotion that's
associated with a memory is something
that's crying out for mastery and
writing can really help with that.
So you're reorganizing your brain.
When you write autobiographically,
you're,
you're basically the emotions.
Imagine emotion memories can be stored
at different levels of your brain,
some sort of primordial reptilian image
laden areas that are very emotional up
to finally articulated plans for your
future life.
Will you want to take everything that's
negative and emotional and transform
that into a fully articulated vision for
your future and that frees you of your
past.
You shouldn't be thinking about your
I mean maybe if you're 80 and you know
you're going over a well spent life,
that's a whole different thing,
but if you're a 30,
35 or 20 and most of the time you
thinking about your past,
it's like it's like your soul is trapped
back there and you need to.
You need to free it through
investigation and the metaphysical
language is appropriate because that is
in a sense what you're doing.
You're trapped in the past.
It's like you've got to break free of
that so you can use all your resources
to move ahead into the future.
Anyways in these programs,
the future authoring program,
like I said,
has had walloping effects on people.
It's dones.
Fantastic advice to me.
It's just so.
It's so logical and it sounds so great.
I mean,
I think that's one of the gigantic
problems that a lot of people have with
education,
that you're learning facts,
you're learning information,
but you're not learning how to use your
own mind.
Now here's something that's really
interesting about that.
So I spent a lot of time.
I'm a scientist,
but I'm also.
I would say I'm also a religious person.
I'm a deeply religious person and how do
you reconcile those?
Exactly.
Well,
that's that.
And I spent literally,
I've spent 40 years thinking about that
and for 20 of those years I did almost
nothing but think about that all the
time and I realized something partly
from Reading Carl young and what I
realized was that
even the fundamentalists have have the
wrong idea about religious truth.
Religious truth is not scientific truth
in the stories in genesis,
which are very old stories,
maybe tens of thousands of years old.
They're obviously not scientific
theories because the people who wrote
the board scientists,
we didn't have science until about 500
years ago.
So the idea that the stories in genesis
or scientific theories is just false on
every possible front.
So then you might say,
well,
there's no other truth,
but scientific truth.
It's like,
well,
wait a minute.
That's not true because what scientific
truth tells you is what things are,
but genuine religious truth tells you
how you should act and those things are
not the same.
And so a great story,
a great novel which is a quasi religious
construction because it's,
it's like a distillation of ordinary
life into its most important elements.
That's a map about how you should
comport yourself in the world.
And you might say,
well what do you mean by should?
And because that's,
that's the question,
the moral relativist Sask.
And there's an answer to that too.
As far as I can tell,
and I got this partly from reading John
Piaget.
So imagine that here's how you should
act.
You should act so that things are good
for you,
like they would be for someone you're
taking care of,
but they have to be good for you in a
way that's also good for your family.
And they have to be good for you and
your family in a way that's also good
for society and maybe even also good for
the broader environment.
If you could manage that so it's
balanced at all those levels and then
they that has to be good for you and
your family and society and the world
right now and next week and next month
and a year from now and 10 years from
now and so it's this harmonious
balancing of multiple layers of being
simultaneously and and that's a.
that's a.
that's a Darwinian reality.
I would say.
Your brain is actually attuned to tell
you when you're doing that and the way
it tells you is that it chew,
it reveals that what you're doing is
meaningful.
That's the sign that you and your
nervous system is adapted to do this.
It's adapted to exist,
I would say on the on the edge between
order and chaos and chaos is where
things are so complex.
You can handle it in order is where
things are so rigid that it's too
restrictive.
In between that there's a place,
a place that's meaningful where you're
partly stabilized and partly curious and
you're operating in a manner that
increases your scope of of knowledge,
so you're.
You're inquiring and growing and at the
same time you're stabilizing and
renewing you,
your family,
society,
nature.
Now,
next week,
next month and next year,
and when you have an intimation of
meaning,
then you know you're there and I can
give you an existential demonstration of
that.
So imagine that each of these levels of
existence,
the way I just laid them out or like
patterns or patterns within patterns,
within patterns,
and there's a way of making all that
harmonious.
That's what music models.
That's why music is so meaningful.
You know,
you take a beautiful orchestral
composition and all the instruments are
doing different things at different
levels,
but they all flow together harmoniously
and you're right in the middle of that
as a listener and it fills you with a
sense of.
It's almost like a sense of religious or
even if you're a punk rock nihilist,
you know,
and the reason for that is because the
music is modeling the manner of being
that's harmonious,
it's the proper way to exist and
religious writings in the deepest sense,
so those are archetipal writings are are
our guidelines to that mode of being so
they're not true like scientific truth
is true there.
I think of them as hyper there
hypertrophy or meditate true.
It's like we take the most true things
about your life and then we take the
most true things about 10 other people's
lives and we amalgamate them into a
single figure and that would be like to.
That would be like a literary hero.
Then we take a thousand literary heroes
and we extract out from each of them
what makes the most heroic person.
That's a religious daddy.
That's what Christ is.
He's a metta hero and that sits at the
bottom of western civilization and his
architectural mode of being his true
speech.
That's the fundamental idea of western
civilization and it's right
now when you say,
when you talk about this harmonious
frequency that's achieved,
what?
How do you reconcile all the stories
that were like say in the Old Testament
that were extremely violent or with
they're ridiculous.
Like,
Oh,
who was the guy that they made fun of,
these children made fun of?
I'm so God sent a bear to kill the
children because they made fun of him
for being bald.
Or there's a bunch of stories and
ridiculous tails in the Bible that
obviously have the hand of man on them.
How do you separate those from the
beautiful concepts that are outlined in
religion?
Like you treat everyone as if they are
your brother,
you know,
love and let love
and that was very,
very difficult because it's all in the
Old Testament.
Let's say the Old Testament was
obviously written by people who were
deeply tribal.
Of course,
we're also deeply tribal and some of the
problems that those people were trying
to face trying to sort out was,
well,
how do you organize yourself within your
own tribe?
Justly and mercifully and at the same
time,
defend yourself against the barbarians
who constitute other drives.
Well,
that was.
That was the problem that humanity was
trying to solve when it was a mega
meeting.
All of its tribes process that obviously
still hasn't,
hasn't finished,
and some of the ways that you protect
your own tribe rapidly become horrifying
and so many of the stories in the Old
Testament that have to do essentially
with tribal protection are immediately
horrifying,
but there's also a.
there's a developmental pathway through
the combination of the old and New
Testament that that,
that show,
I would say how that morality that was
fundamentally tribal to begin with
transformed itself over thousands of
years into a morality that was what that
transcended tribal distinctions and so
part of the imposition of the new
testament onto the old testament was the
imposition of a morality that
transcended tribal morality onto a
morality that was fundamentally tribal
in origin.
But the new testament of course was
constructed by Constantine and the
series of bishops.
They took things out.
I mean how so?
Well,
it's not much different.
Here's a way of thinking about it,
so I have a friend who's a comic book
writer and I've talked to him a fair bit
about archetypes in comics.
For example.
He was a student of mine at Harvard long
time ago and the Comic Book Universe is
a very interesting one because obviously
these fictional characters were thought
up by single people and then the
fictional characters were transformed
into stories and then the stories were
sent out into a broader community.
But then what started to happen was the
broader community started to stay in
contact with the people who are writing
the stories and so if you do something
like write Batman now,
there's a bunch of things you can't do
with Batman because there's been a
collective decision made in the entire
community of multiple writers and the
entire community of multiple readers
that have decided that there's a core
story that has a certain structure in
certain elements.
And so there's this collective process
of imagination that's gone into
constructing what you might describe as
a heroic Meta narrative.
And
the reason I'm using that as an example
is because there isn't a lot of
difference,
perversely enough in the construction,
say of Comic Book Heroes and the
construction of religious deities,
and I'm not saying that religious
daddies or nothing but comic book
characters or maybe I'm elevating comic
book characters beyond the status that
they normally attained.
But if you think,
think about this,
for example,
with regards to something like the
construction of the recent marvel
universe,
I mean those avenger movies are among
the most expensive technological
artifacts that human beings have ever
made and they drive our computational
capacity to its absolute limit.
And the reason for that is because we're
using that fictional space to lay out an
archetypical and mythological view of
the universe.
It's a practice domain for modes of
being.
And I mean in the Marvel Universe,
obviously Tony Stark Ironman is,
is technological man,
right?
He's trying to develop a real
relationship with his partner pepper
potts whose own sort of independent
woman and he's attempting to use
technology to build himself up into
something that has the status of
approximately a god to transcend more
limitation.
And all of that,
um,
so there's a,
there's a daddy like aspect,
the growth of a deity emerging there,
and then of course thor and Loki,
or they're not comic book ease at all.
Their actual daddy's there,
the hostile brothers.
It's an archetypal,
it's an archetype will pair like Christ
and Satan or Batman and the joker or
superman and Lex luthor.
And that's the good part of the
individual against the evil part of the
individual,
roughly speaking,
that's played out in these myths.
And so that collective process that you
described whereby an entire group of
people comes together to decide what the
central religious text is.
I mean,
on the one hand you can think of that as
the gerrymandering of a religious
process.
Maybe that's something that's only
devoted towards the acquisition of
power.
Like that would be a Marxist analysis.
But on the other hand,
you can think of it as the collective
imagination.
Attempting to build a dramatic,
uh,
to build,
to build a and exemplary drama that
everyone can act out.
And it's,
it's enacting that exemplary drama that
we're actually able to interact in a
civilized and productive manner.
Like look at this discussion that we're
having to,
to the degree that it's working,
we're both trying to articulate our
notions of reality and I do that and you
listen and maybe you have some comments
and then you do that and I listened and
maybe you have some comments,
but together we're building something
that's different from what we both came
in here with.
Right,
and in a sense what we're doing is we're
participating in the process of
articulating each other's spirits and I
mean that most technically like part of
your spirit is an amalgam of the
information that you've encountered.
A lot of that is articulated,
articulated wisdom and so its sole
construction.
If you're having a good conversation and
that's also conversation that is
meaningful and you can tell that when
you're having it,
it's that you're.
You're decomposing parts of yourself,
your false presuppositions,
you're letting them die and you're
letting something new be born as an
alternative and you're participating in
this process of death and rebirth
constantly.
When you're having a meaningful
conversation,
it's like,
oh,
that was wrong.
Honey,
let that die.
Oh,
that's a little painful.
I was kind of attached to that concept,
but I'll let it go,
let it burn off,
and a new part of you will emerge and
then another part dies and the new part
emerges,
and that's this process of eternal death
and rebirth.
It's part of to the general mythology of
redemption and you see that all the time
too,
and the Harry Potter series,
for example,
at the very end of the Harry Potter
series,
Potter undergoes a literal death and
rebirth and that's how he finally
defeats evil.
These stories are deeply built into
people.
There's a reason that that jk rowling
became the richest person in England by
she's richer than the queen.
She got rich by telling the story
properly,
you know,
and the second volume of Harry Potter,
when,
when there's the basilisk underneath the
castle that turns you to stone.
When you look at it,
that's everything that people are afraid
of that freezes you.
Like a rabbit freezes when it sees a
wolf and the story and Harry Potter is
you go underneath the castle to where
the thing that fear frightens you the
most resides and you face it down and in
doing that,
you free the virgin,
right?
That St George,
he frees Virginia and the Harry Potter
Story and maybe you have died because of
that,
because he gets bitten by that.
Baskets can just about dies and then
it's the phoenix that saves them because
the Phoenix is the spirit of death and
rebirth.
These stories,
they come up everywhere.
There's no avoiding them and it's
because they're true,
but they're not true like scientific
truths.
There are different.
There are behavioral truth,
if are a pragmatic truth or a dramatic
truth,
and part of the reason that our society
is so damn on stable now and part of the
reason all this weird chaos is emerging.
This is a consequence of niches
observation back from the late 18
hundreds about the death of God.
We blew the metaphysical foundations out
from underneath our culture and the
whole thing is shaking and twisting and
it's.
It's vacillating between the horrors of
the extreme,
right and the horrors of the extreme
left.
It's been doing that for 140 years and
we're in the throes of that.
Again,
we blew the metaphysical foundations out
from underneath her culture and we need
to get them back.
Part of the reason that people are so
obsessed by things like the avengers
movies and superheros and Harry Potter
and all of that is because,
and Star Trek and star wars is because
our,
our collective imagination is trying to
regroup at the level of drama and
reformulate our fundamental metaphysics.
I was reading this thing that was
talking.
They were equating crossfit and yoga to
religion and they were saying it's
essentially religion for people that
have abandoned traditional religions.
Is that the idea is that we'll receiving
is camaraderie or and discipline
discipline and some sort of a shared
community experience.
So when you're talking about when you're
saying your religion,
you're not talking about a literal
translation like a guy actually came
back from the dead.
Well,
you're talking about is the concepts and
the thoughts and the harmonious
frequency that is achieved when people
follow the tenets of that religion and
live by these laws.
As you were saying of stacking on these
ideas,
is this good for you?
Is it good for the community?
Is it good for the community in five
years,
in 10 years,
and in that,
that that's what you're saying when
you're talking about,
well,
you're believing love,
relationship thing about that is that
like imagine that there's,
there's a pathological mode of being
that so terrible that when you enact it,
you just die.
A good drug addiction will do that for
you.
If you had pursued that meth addiction,
pursue that for about 10 years,
you know,
and you'll descend to the lower levels
of hell and then you'll die.
Right?
Well,
so then you might might say,
well,
what's,
what's at the opposite end of that?
What would be the final manifestation of
a mode of life that was revivifying and
healthy?
How,
how,
how redemptive and rejuvenating would
that be?
And I would say the answer to that is
that we don't know.
We have no idea and these ideas of death
and rebirth are definitely true on the
micro level,
like so.
The developmental psychologist Piaget
said,
for example,
that when you incorporated new
information,
however you did that learning or
conversation that that new information
would exist in in contradiction to
something that you already presumed and
so that thing you presumed would have to
disintegrate and die and and then
something new will be born.
That can happen at different levels of
analysis,
so sometimes you learn something minor
and sometimes you're shook to your
bloody core,
you know,
and and you undergo a descent into the
underworld fundamentally,
sometimes even a descent into hell.
That's where you get genocidal and
resentful and then maybe you're lucky
and you pop up reborn.
Well,
those,
those exist as,
as constant metaphysical truths that
that's how human beings transformed.
We don't know the upper limits of that
transformation.
We have no idea what that might be
because I don't know,
for example,
how healthy you could be as if you were
as healthy as you could be if you
straightened yourself out completely.
I don't know what,
what your.
What limits you could transcend and
neither does anybody else,
so we don't know the upper limits of the
truth of these religious stories.
Now we do know what happens if you let
go of them too badly.
You end up with something like the
Soviet Union or Mao's China,
which were both based on.
I mean,
they,
they were atheist,
man.
They were secular.
They were,
they,
uh,
that they dispense.
You know,
for Marx it was religion was the opiate
of the masses.
It's like,
it's not like,
I don't understand that,
I understand that,
but it's another one of those situations
where it's like religion is the opiate
of the masses.
Yeah.
And it's also 50 other things and you
don't want to forget those.
Like really we know for example,
from studies,
religious
belief as a human universal.
And the reason for that in part is
because there is a distinction between
good and evil and there is a distinction
between good and bad.
Otherwise you wouldn't do anything like
you're always striving for the good.
I mean,
unless you've taken a malevolent turn,
it's a natural impulse in human beings
to make what is better.
While it means we have an.
We have a deeply inbuilt sense of what
constitutes better and we're all aware
of that harmonious state that's achieved
well.
Well,
yeah.
No.
The thing that's interesting about it,
like one of the things that need your
thought was after he announced the death
of God was that people would be able to
create new values and Carl Jung took
issue with that.
He was a student of niches and he
pointed out basically that,
well,
wait a minute,
who says you can create your own values?
You can't even get yourself out of bed
to go exercise in the morning.
You're not under your own control.
Maybe we could discover maybe we could
rediscover the values that we once held
and that's the descent into the
underworld and the resurrection of the
father.
That's what happens in Pinocchio.
For example,
you know when Pinocchio goes down into
the depths to face monster and
revitalized his dead father,
there's a reason that movie was made in
the 19 thirties and why it was so
popular.
It's like you want to have.
You want to get rid of your damn strings
and stopped being an erotic jackass.
That's what this story's about is you go
down to the bottom of the ocean.
You find the thing you're most afraid
of.
You face it,
you rescue your dead father from the
depths and you rise back to the surface
with him.
That's what our culture has to do.
Now,
when you say that your religious person
though,
people automatically assume that you
know there's,
especially in this country,
the religious right,
there's a very,
a dogmatic and very simplistic view of
what God wants and the.
I mean it,
it,
it's lumped into no homosexuals,
a certain restrictions on the behavior
of women.
That if you look at the Bible and the
Bible is obviously a reflection of the
people that lived at the time where it
was constructed.
Although even trying to figure out when
that is,
you know,
an oral tradition for thousands of years
before it was ever written down,
written in ancient Hebrew,
translated to Latin and Greek and Roman
or and I'm English rather.
Well,
there's always a tension in religions
between the dogmatic element in this
spiritual element and conservatives
technically speaking,
tend to tend to Marshall themselves on
the sides of the more rule oriented and
dogmatic elements of the religion and
liberals roughly speaking,
tend to Marshall themselves more on the
spiritual side
and that's because of the distinction
that you were saying earlier about the
behavior patterns of people that
conservative conscientiousness versus
openness.
Roughly speaking,
and I mean the dogmatic structures are
necessarily necessary.
The dogma is necessary because it
conserves the structure,
but a spiritual aspect is necessary
because it updates the and there's
always this tension and there's a
tension in people.
It's like you have to believe things
are.
You couldn't exist.
You couldn't act.
You have to hold onto the dogmatic
structure of your belief,
but you have to be open for its update
on a continual basis and that's well,
that's basically what consciousness is
for that.
Seriously speaking consciousness is the
thing that attends to the unknown into
the anomaly and integrates it with the
structure and there's meaning to be
found in that too.
That's,
that's to boldly go where no one has
gone before.
You know,
in the,
in the words of the Star Trek Writers
and something that deeply appeals to
young people when they watch that sort
of thing.
But so what the fundamentalists are
doing is they're trying to hold onto
their tradition and it's no bloody
wonder because if,
if the tradition falls apart,
you end up isolated and drowning in the
ocean alone.
But if the tradition gets too intense
and restricted,
well then then you're just clones in a
prison.
And that's these.
That's these two,
two forms of hell in a sense.
They meet,
you know,
if they get extreme enough,
they meet the hell of absolute chaos and
the hell of absolute order.
And,
and the Conservatives tend towards the
hail of absolute order and that and the
left liberal types tend towards the hell
of absolute chaos.
There's some point in the middle that's
the line between Yin and Yang by the
way,
because that's order and chaos and the
Dow is say,
well,
that's life.
That's existence.
Order in chaos and order is the place
you are when what you do works and chaos
is where you are when what you do
doesn't work and no matter where you go,
order and chaos exist and your job is to
be right on the border between those and
that's to live in Dow,
that's to live in meaning and that's
that same place where all these things
stack up and so well on.
So with regards to religious tradition,
on the one hand you have to maintain the
tradition.
It's like maintaining the constitution
in the US.
On the other hand,
you have to be awake and alert because
the tradition is a dead thing,
right?
It was composed by dead people in the
dead past.
It can't respond as flexibly as it
should to the demands of the present.
That's up to you and you do that with
your vision,
with your capacity to see and with your
capacity to,
to articulate and forever forever really
the major deities that mankind have
produced Marta,
for the Mesopotamians oh,
cyrus or horace horace for the Egyptians
and and Christ for the Christians and
Buddha for the Buddhists.
These [inaudible] have been people who
are noted for their vision,
for their ability to watch and pay
attention because there's nothing more
important than the ability to pay
attention,
pay attention and speak the truth,
your truth,
and that's how you keep everything
stacked up in order harmoniously.
That's how you keep the balance between
order and chaos.
That's how you articulate your being.
That's how you revivify the world.
That's how you rescue your dead father
from the bottom of the ocean.
That's how you adopt your responsibility
as a citizen.
That's how you live a proper life and a
proper life.
I know what a proper life is because I
thought about this for a long time.
Life is suffering and suffering can make
you resentful,
murderous,
and then genocidal if you take it far
enough so you need an antidote to
suffering and maybe you know you could
think,
well,
I'll build walls of luxury around myself
and that'll protect me from the
suffering.
It's like,
well,
good luck with that because that isn't
going to work and maybe you could build
a delusion and live inside that,
but now it's going to fall apart.
Well,
what is there that helps you fight
against suffering?
That's easy.
That's the truth.
The truth is the antidote to suffering
and the reason for that is because the
truth puts reality behind you so that
you can face the reality that's coming
straight at you without becoming weak
and degenerating and becoming resentful
and wishing for the destruction of being
because that's the final hell.
The final hail is your soul wishing for
the destruction of everything because
it's too painful and you're too bitter,
and that happens to people all the time.
Now,
as a person who is someone who's
extremely critical of ideologies,
a lot of people would think it's a
contradiction for you to embrace
religion because religion being the
biggest and oldest ideology ideology is
a parasite on religious substructures.
You can't look.
We could go back to the Harry Potter
example.
That's a good example.
I mean,
jk rowling had kids reading like 400
page books,
right?
She could fill a stadium when she was
reading.
Why is because she got the archetypes,
right?
She got the religious sub narratives,
correct.
They're not ideologies.
Ideologies work because an etiology is a
parasite on top of a religious
substructure and a religious.
A religious narrative has has a
particular set of characteristics.
It's very balanced.
So for example,
there's the feminist idea of the
patriarchy.
While the religious idea of society has
an evil patriarchy notion built into it,
that would be the dying king.
The once great dying king.
You see this in the Egyptian story of
Osiris,
for example,
who's eventually chopped up by his evil
brother.
You see it in the lion king with a,
with a Fossa and a symbols.
Symbols farther in symbols,
evil,
evil uncle,
those are the two representatives of the
patriarchy,
the wise king in the tyrannical king in
a religious story,
properly setup archetypal story.
There's,
there's the natural world,
the chaotic world.
There's a positive element and a
negative element.
There's the social world,
there's the wise king and the tyrannical
king and there's the individual world
and now it's the the adversary and the
hero.
There's always a positive and a negative
at each level and it stops it from being
an oversimplification because it says to
you,
well,
of course society is oppressive.
Patriarchy,
but it's also the wise farther that has
taught you to speak every word you know.
It's like you don't get to say only this
part of the story without having
gratitude for this part of this story,
and it's true at at each level of the
representation of properly balanced
story is how has got the balance between
positive and negative.
Always correct.
Is that in many ways,
like a lot of people who are anti
western capitalism are also the only.
They will find that capitalism in
western capitalism in particular is the
only culture that is embraced the
acceptance of people like transgender
people,
people who are gay,
people who are marginalized.
I mean Western capitalist society is one
of the very few cultures that openly
oppose racism.
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
and these people are anticapitalist on
their iphones.
Right.
You don't get to do that.
It's a performative contradiction.
So that's so important.
Yeah.
They're on their iphones while they're
flying.
Yeah.
Capitalists.
It's like,
well,
actually no,
you're not.
You're just deeply confused as what you
are is deeply confused.
It's not capitalism.
That's the problem.
It's evil.
It's a problem.
It's.
Well,
it's also the deeper probe it evil is a
problem.
So there's a religious scholar named
Mercy Eliana who looked at flood myths
because there are flood myths all over
the world.
God gets fed up,
floods everything.
It's like,
just like in New Orleans.
So here's a funny thing about New
Orleans.
What caused the New Orleans flood or
hurricane?
No,
no.
How about human corruption?
How about the corruption of,
of,
of the state.
How about the fact that people knew the
dam,
dykes,
we're going to hold that the levies
weren't going to hold,
how about that?
They knew that for 100 years and didn't
care.
How about that?
They pocketed the money that should have
gone for the repair.
And so in flood myths,
you always see two things.
You see that I'm paraphrasing,
say there's a storm,
there's dykes,
and there's people responsible for
maintaining the dikes.
Well,
the storm will wipe out the city,
it could,
but if the dikes are high enough that it
won't,
and if people aren't corrupt and they
build the dikes properly,
and so god floods the world when the
dikes have rotted and the people have
become corrupt and it's a very old story
and it's disseminated everywhere.
And the reason is as well,
we inhabit a,
uh,
a social structure that's old and,
and,
and dad,
our infrastructures dictate our,
our,
our political,
economic and practical infrastructure
has decade.
Why it's old everything to case,
okay?
Everything's already always decaying.
That's dangerous and corrupt.
People don't do a very good job of
keeping an order.
And so if things get old and decayed
enough,
and if people get corrupt enough,
then God floods the world.
Why?
Because that's what happens over and
over and over and over and over.
And you don't mean in the literal sense
of the word.
You mean God as these are the
consequences to these types of actions.
You are not prepared for what you
transcended reality.
You could look at it that way.
You know?
And,
and I mean the idea of God is a very,
very complicated idea,
but you could say if you were thinking
about it merely merely from an
intellectual perspective is you could
say that God is what transcends your
knowledge.
That's all.
It's just,
it's what you don't know.
It's what's outside of your knowledge
structures.
And there's a very old story,
and this goes all the way back to the
Tower of Babel,
is that one of the things that
characterizes authoritarians is that
there's never anything outside of their
knowledge structures.
They make their notes structures
absolute.
So in the Tower of Babel,
human beings build this structure that's
supposed to reach all the way to have it
too.
So that we can invade the place of the
gods.
Well,
God has none of that.
He just blows it apart and throws people
all over the world.
And it's a very early dramatic
representation of the danger of human
hubris.
And hubris is we know everything.
There's nothing that needs to be left
outside of what we know.
It's like,
no,
that's what God is.
God is what's always outside of what you
know is the problem with the term God
though the people think of God as being
a man,
they think of it being a person.
They even use the masculine pronouns in
reference to God.
I mean,
that's one of the funniest things about
God is calling him a he.
Well,
it's an APP problem.
I mean,
and,
and that's certainly been a problem.
Young talked about that a lot about the,
the exclusion of the feminine within the
domains of Classic Judaeo Christian
thought.
For example.
I mean,
you have Mary who's,
who's a kind of a cause identity,
who,
who pops in sort of like as a fourth
member of the trinity.
But the exclusion of the feminine is
definitely a conceptual problem.
Um,
is the fact that God is conceptualized
as a human being or as a man a problem?
It's a problem.
And the solution,
I mean if you,
if you remove the human element of God,
then God gets so abstract that it's easy
for him to float off into space and to
never show up again.
Can you lose the human connection?
I mean the way the Catholic solve that
to some degree is that they have God who
sort of at the top of the hierarchy and
then they have this hierarchy of saints
who were sort of like gods but half
human and then they have human beings at
the bottom.
And that allows for a,
what would you say,
a continual chain of communication
between the highest level of abstraction
in the actual,
you know,
the actual concrete person.
But,
but the other,
the other thing that's useful about the
conceptualization of God in
anthropomorphic terms is that,
and this is worth noting,
is there is nothing more complex in the
cosmos than a human being.
So if you're looking for something to
represent the ultimate didn't
complexity,
it's hard to beat a human being.
So your brain is ungodly complicated,
so to speak.
So I mean these things are obviously too
complicated to unpack in a,
in a.
In a way I didn't expect to get into
conversation,
but
I'm glad we did.
D,
do you think that these stories exist
because somewhere in our code,
somewhere in our very being,
we understand that there is a need for
this order to find this frequency so
they're sure they're an expression of
our deepest being there.
They're an expression of how it is that
we must live in order to live in order
to reach our full potential.
Even more than that,
more than that,
even to avoid hell and you can take the.
All you can think about hell is Nazi
Germany.
If you want,
you can think about it as the Soviet
Gulag archipelago or Mao's cultural
revolution like we can get there.
No problem.
If you,
you walk down in some of the seedier
areas in La,
you'll see people in hell no problem.
Sure.
Go to skid row.
Yes,
yes.
And you can tell where the,
when those people are there,
because they will get angry.
If you look at them and you'll,
you'll walk a big birth around them.
You're not going to come within 10 feet
of the,
let's call it psycho,
geography of their existence.
Right,
and that they're,
they're in a place,
it's a metaphysical place,
but it's,
it's not defined by the dam geography,
you know,
skid row is as much of a psychological
place as it is a physical place.
In fact,
it's more that Maura psychological
place,
but that doesn't make it any less a
place and if you're descend into the
hell of skid row deep enough,
you'll get to the point where most of
your thoughts or murderous and that's
like,
that's,
that's hell as a suburb of the
underworld.
Fundamentally those,
that place exists.
People visited all the time and
sometimes they don't get out.
It's real.
I've been discussing this a lot recently
because people like to talk about the
concept of apocalypse,
that we're headed towards an impending
apocalypse and my thought is that
apocalypse is already here.
It's just not right here.
Yeah.
It's always go to Liberia,
go to Liberia and look at people,
devastating this treats and eating human
flesh.
I mean they do.
I don't know if you've ever seen the
vice piece on Liberia,
but it's.
It's unbelievably terrifying.
The whole live there,
the apocalypse is the apocalypse is an
archetypal idea and the apocalypse is
always here and it's here.
It's here at the micro level,
like when we have a discussion in our
concepts change.
Those are micro apocalypses,
little bits of our being are being blown
apart and restructured and that can be
happen at a small scale or large scale
or it can.
It can get to the point where everything
collapses and is destroyed and life is
apocalyptic in that matter because we
all get sick.
We all die.
You know,
our families,
our vulnerable.
There's an apocalyptic element to being
and we and we have to face that and
confronted and deal with it properly
and,
and the wrong way to deal with it is to,
is to,
is to generate more hell than heaven I
suppose,
and to do that consciously.
And people do that all the time too.
There's never a situation that's so bad
that there isn't something you can do to
make it worse and there's very seldomly
a time when you're not motivated at some
level of your being to put the knife in
and twist it.
Just one more quarter turn.
People are like that and we have reason.
Life is hard.
It's no wonder people get corrupted by
it.
It's not an easy thing to.
To live in a.
it's not an easy thing to live,
let's say in a truthful manner,
but,
but the alternative,
the alternative is hell.
I mean,
part of the reason that I made these
videos to begin with was because,
and I learned a lot about the importance
of spoken truth as a,
as a,
as the countervailing force against
tyranny and authoritarianism.
It isn't an alternative political
structure.
That's the countervailing force.
It's,
it's this,
it's spoken truth.
That's the countervailing force.
It's like,
well,
why would I put my job on the line to
have an opinion about compelled
pronouns?
I know why,
because the ability to speak your truth
is the bulwark against hell
and losing your job.
That's nothing.
That's nothing compared to where things
can go when they go badly.
For me it was just preventative.
It's like this isn't going in a good
direction.
Well,
should you take a risk?
It's like you don't have that choice.
You're silent.
That's a risk.
Now.
Most people don't understand the risks
of silence.
I happen to understand the risks of
sadness because I had been studying them
for 40 years.
Is it frustrating for you to get so
little support for these actions and
for,
for your,
your protests?
Well,
I,
I wouldn't say that that's what happened
and I don't mean so little support
because you're going a lot of support
outside of the,
in the outside of the university.
It's okay.
It doesn't matter where the support
comes from.
Like I mean it's,
it's disappointing in the same way that
it's disappointing for me to say.
I think the universities now do more
harm than good.
That's disappointing,
but.
But it,
it doesn't,
it's not surprising to me.
I guess it isn't as if intellectuals are
characterized by an intrinsic moral
superiority.
Oh,
they're smart.
So they'll leap to the defense of what's
right.
It's like,
no,
there's no evidence for that
intelligence and and moral wisdom aren't
the same thing like and if you're
corrupt and smart,
all that makes you is way more
treacherous.
It doesn't make you less likely to be
corrupt.
It just makes you much more your 50
snakes instead of two or your 56 headed
snakes instead of to like I've had
clients who were,
who had very serious personality
disorders,
who are very intelligent.
It's like that's not necessarily a good
thing for them.
They're just better at arguing for their
pathology to.
That is a real problem where people
automatically assume that intelligent
people are going to be healthy.
Yeah,
well they're healthy in that often
psychological,
better in the world,
you know,
because because their skills are more
marketable and so on,
but there's no evidence that there's any
relationship between intelligence and
morality.
I mean,
God,
let me tell you a story man.
One time I have this client,
this woman was just ruined.
She looked like a street person,
you know,
and she had very dirty clothes and she
was so shy that she couldn't even
approach you.
She had to shield her eyes from you as
if you are emitting light.
And she did that to everyone on the
street,
like he was bent over and,
and,
and humble,
like a,
like a Chinese peasant brought before
the emperor,
you know.
And uh,
one of the things I was doing with her
and behavior therapy was trying to just
get her to present herself in a more
normal manner so that people wouldn't
shy away from her and be instantly
prejudice towards her.
And she'd come to the behavior therapy
clinic and she wasn't bright.
This woman thinks she had only had like
a seventh grade education.
She was quite intellectually impaired
and she lived with her.
Her sick aunt who was,
who has schizophrenia and who had a,
like a,
a satanic possessed alcoholic boyfriend
that was always tormenting my client.
She lived in absolute hell,
but she had this dog and she used to
take it out and walk the dog all the
time.
And then she,
she'd actually come to the behavior
therapy clinic partly because of her own
problem.
But,
but she'd come to this place called the
Douglas Hospital and she'd been an
inpatient in the Douglas Hospital in
India,
in the Douglas Hospital.
There were these long term psychiatric
clients and they looked like something
out of a Hieronymus Bosch painting or
Dante's inferno.
I mean these people were.
This is way worse than one flew over the
cuckoo's nest.
These people were seriously destroyed
and they couldn't be let back out in the
streets during deinstitutionalization,
like they were lifers and she had
decided that part of the reason she
wanted to come to the hospitalist
because she had been institutionalized
there and she thought that maybe when
she took her dog out for a walk,
she could go and get one of those damn
inmates and take them out for a walk to
now that was a person who is a moral
dumb as a post,
just screwed in 50 different directions.
Nothing going for her.
And she had that bloody moral capacity
to decide that there was someone worse
off than her and believe me,
that wasn't easy to find and that maybe
she could do them some good.
If,
if the hospital would letter,
which they didn't,
by the way.
Yeah,
well that's the story of the soul.
That's not the intellect,
that's for sure.
So,
so I didn't expect any support from my,
from my colleagues.
And it isn't that I don't care if I got
it,
but it's,
it's in some sense it's irrelevant.
It's irrelevant to me because my goal
was,
I'm not saying those God damn pronouns
and the,
I'm not saying them
is because they're made up by left wing
ideologues and I don't like left wing
ideology.
I don't like ediology period and I know
where
corruption of speech leads and I'm not
going there.
And you know,
one of the things I tried to learn when
I was taking apart what happened in
Auschwitz and trying to put myself in
the position of an Auschwitz camp guard,
which by the way you can do,
if you use your imagination a bit,
I wouldn't call it exactly the world's
most pleasant meditative experience,
but you can call up parts of yourself
that would be capable of taking someone
who just got off a transport train and
having them carry a 100 pound sack of
wet salt from one side of the camp
compound to the other and back.
You can conjure that part of yourself up
if you want.
And that'll teach you something about
what you're like.
People don't do it because it's too
frightening,
but I know perfectly well that I could
do that sort of thing.
And so once I learned that I could do
that sort of thing and maybe that I
could even enjoy it,
I thought,
okay,
fine.
I get it.
I'm going to see if I can figure out how
to live so that if that opportunity was
presented to me,
I wouldn't take it.
And I think that's the lesson that
people need to learn from the 20th
century.
It's like that's what human beings did.
Okay,
well we're all human.
so how is it that we should live so that
we don't do that again?
Well,
part of that is to try to say the truth
no matter what,
because the alternative is worse and it
is worse.
The truth no matter what.
And that is the real problem that you
see with being forced into using these
made up pronouns.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's my language all take responsibility
for what I say I have not say in your
words and being compelled to say your
words by law.
Well that's that,
that,
that makes it,
that that takes it past the point of
absurdity to the point of tyranny in,
in my estimation.
And I,
and I've seen some criticisms where
people are saying,
you know,
he's talking about this,
but really he's grandstanding because no
one's doing anything legally,
but the potential exists such rubbish.
But that is one of the arguments.
Yes,
they wouldn't have changed the damn
criminal.
They put it in the hate speech category
and altered the criminal code.
It's as simple as that,
and then you could say,
well,
no,
we didn't really mean it.
It's like,
oh yeah,
you did.
You really meant it to have the social
justice warriors that have debated being
the last two months accused me directly
of hate speech.
All I had to do was poke them a tiny bit
and they came right out with it and then
the university's legal team reviewed
everything I said carefully believed me
and they decided that,
oh,
it was not only illegal to not use these
compelled pronouns.
It was probably illegal to make a video
saying that I wouldn't use them because
otherwise why would they write me a
warning letter and tell me that I
violated university policy on the
Ontario Human Rights Act?
They did that lightly.
Have they acted on this at all?
Is there they won't know.
Well acted in that.
They sent me to warning,
reverse and told me to stop talking and
the idea that I was going to be teaching
in January again because I teach all my
undergraduate courses from January to
May that was on the table and I think
the only reason that it hasn't happened,
one of the reasons it hasn't happened
and I'm not attributing nothing but
malevolence to the university
administration because obviously it's
very complicated and they did agree to
host the debate,
for example,
but the idea that I wouldn't be teaching
in January and still might not be is by
no means that was a perfectly plausible
outcome and had this not caused a
firestorm much of which has emerged in
supportive me.
Then I would say there was a 50 slash 50
chance that I would've had my teaching
privileges revoked,
tabbing to other professors.
So the idea that I'm making it,
I like that this is a tempest in a
teapot.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
fine.
Why did you change the criminal code
then?
And why'd you put it under the hate
speech laws?
Exactly.
So no doesn't wash
and I.
and the fundamental proof of that is the
university's response because for sure
there are legal team crafted those
letters in recalcitrant employee,
you're responsible for them.
Okay,
what do you do with a recalcitrant
employed?
You write them a letter telling them
what they're doing wrong and asking them
to stop.
Then if they don't stop,
you write them a second letter that's
more strongly worded.
Then if they don't stop,
you write them a third letter,
even more strongly worded.
Then you take disciplinary action.
That's like her one on one.
That's how you do it.
So,
so here we said at the end of November,
a closing on December,
you're literally a a bit more than a
month away and you don't know whether or
not you're teaching your courses.
In January,
it seems highly probable that I'll be
teaching them.
I wouldn't say it's certain,
but if I'm teaching them,
it's because the cost of having me not
teach them would now be too high.
It's not because the university believes
that what I'm doing is either necessary
or acceptable.
If someone who's listening to this or
watching this feels compelled to act out
in your support,
how can they do that?
I think they could do the future
authoring exercise and that that would
be the best way to act out and you're,
I'm,
I'm dead serious about this is like sort
yourself out,
sort yourself out before you try to
figure out the world and the past.
That's the primary objective.
That's your,
that's your most important thing that
you can do so yourself out sort yourself
out and,
and Marshall your arguments and put
yourself in order so that when someone
pushes you a little farther than you
should go,
you can say no and you know what's going
on
now.
Yeah,
I think that's outstanding advice.
That's very,
very important advice.
And uh,
I think this has been one of my favorite
podcasts ever.
I really appreciate you coming on.
I appreciate everything you've done.
I appreciate you having the courage to
stick your neck out and I appreciate
also,
you're incredibly well thought out
arguments for the,
for those actions,
so thank you.
Thank you.
How do people get Ahold of your youtube
page?
What is your youtube page?
Was the Jordan Peterson videos,
Jordan Peterson videos on youtube and do
you use twitter?
I know you put your twitter page out,
but you use it so.
And that is Jordan,
Jordan,
b Peterson Peterson,
yeah.
Okay.
Thank you sir.
I really,
really appreciate it.
It was a.
It was an honor.
Thank you.
Thanks for the invitation.
Sia.